Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zu Nummer 53 unserer Reise durch Wissenschaft und alles, was da noch mit dranhängt.
Und heute wollen wir mal ein Thema aufgreifen, was die Welt bewegt, was Deutschland bewegt, was glaube ich auch irgendwie eins der wichtigsten Themen ist, die man derzeit so beackern kann im wissenschaftlichen Feld.
Was hier auch immer wieder mal anklang, aber noch nie so im Fokus stand, und zwar die Energiewende.
Den langen Weg zu einem Wandel in der Energieerzeugung und in der Energienutzung.
Und dazu begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner, Volker Quaschning, schönen guten Tag.
Ja hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Herr Quaschning, Sie sind Professor an der Hochschule für Technik und Wirtschaft zu Berlin.
Sagt man so? Zu Berlin klingt immer ein bisschen höfischer.
Wir sagen HTW Berlin.
Genau HTW. Eine Hochschule, die ja eigentlich recht neu ist kann man sagen oder?
Ja, also viele Hochschulen haben ja eine Tradition, die mehrere hunderte Jahre vielleicht sogar zurückgehen.
Unsere Hochschule ist eigentlich erst nach der Wende entstanden.
Es gab Vorläuferinstitutionen zu DDR-Zeiten, wir sind ja im Ostteil von Berlin.
Aber als richtig eigenständige Hochschule ist man dann halt erst seit gut 20 Jahren jetzt unterwegs.
Aber das hat auch Vorteile oder, wenn man diesen ganzen Ballast der Vergangenheit nicht mit sich herumschleppt?
Na ich bin ja schon seit über 10 Jahren dabei.
Am Anfang, als ich gekommen bin, war das sehr erfrischend.
Ich kenne ja andere Institutionen, man hat einfach nicht diesen Wasserkopf und diese eingefahrenen Strukturen.
Verwaltungsstrukturen sind halt immer auch manchmal kompliziert.
Die älter die Institution ist, desto komplizierter werden die Verwaltungsvorgänge.
Da sehe ich jetzt aber auch, also 20 Jahre ist jetzt auch nicht mehr ganz brandjung, das heißt es wird auch manches komplizierter.
Es dickt an.
Aber trotzdem, HTW ich kenne das ja hier so ein bisschen aus Berlin, war auf jeden Fall so ein belebendes Element.
Einerseits für den Bezirk da unten, Oberschöneweide, war auf jeden Fall auch so einer der Bereiche, die extremen Wandel durchgezogen haben so nach der Wende.
Wie so viele, aber dort halt auch durch eine ganz andere Ausrichtung, eine sehr industrielle Positionierung ja damals.
Elektrowerke etc., das ist ja da so ein bisschen der Ursprung.
Da passt die HTW ja ganz gut rein oder?
Ja perfekt. Ich meine, wir sind ja doch eine sehr quirlige lebendige Hochschule, mit sehr verschiedenen Studiengängen.
Also bei uns kann man wirklich alles klassische studieren, bis halt hin zu erneuerbaren Energien, wo ich herkomme.
Wir haben am Standort noch Modedesign, das sind dann immer so diese Kontraste, die eigentlich sehr spannend sind.
Und das Ganze natürlich im alten Industrieambiente.
Also wer vor Ort mal gewesen ist, wunderschöne Gebäude aus der Gründerzeit, die für uns dann renoviert wurden.
Und die Geschichte geht sehr lange zurück.
Man hat am Standort, wenn man einfach mal den Bezug zur Energiewende macht, sogar schon mal Elektroautos gebaut.
Das ist allerdings über 100 Jahre her.
Ach ernsthaft?
Jaja, also das Thema ist ja nicht …
Und wer hat die da gebaut?
Ach keine Ahnung, wie damals der Hersteller hieß, es gibt noch so alte Fotos, also zur letzten Jahrhundertwende.
Dann war das AEG relativ lange das Gebäude.
Zu DDR-Zeiten hatten wir da Kabelwerke Oberspree, mit wirklich zehntausenden von Arbeitern.
Und nach der Wende eigentlich im Prinzip alles abgewickelt, ein sterbender Bezirk.
Und seid einigen Jahren sind wir mit der Hochschule da.
Und der Bezirk belebt sich und wir sind eigentlich ganz glücklich.
Der Standort ist auch wunderschön an der Spree gelegen.
Also wer einmal da ist, will eigentlich gar nicht mehr weg.
Ihr Studiengang, oder den Studiengang, den Sie betreuen, Umwelttechnik regenerative Energien, dafür ist die Professur dann auch eingerichtet worden?
Genau. Wir haben seit über 20 Jahren einen Studiengang zu erneuerbaren Energien an der HTW.
Das heißt eine der ersten Hochschulen weltweit, also nicht weltweit, da gab es vielleicht noch ein paar andere, aber zumindest mal deutschlandweit sind wir ganz vorne mit dabei.
Mittlerweile kann man das ja an dutzenden von Hochschulen studieren, aber vor 20 Jahren war das noch ein ziemliches Alleinstellungsmerkmal.
Das wurde sukzessive aufgebaut, wir haben jetzt 11 Professuren in dem Bereich, die ausschließlich die erneuerbaren Energien beackern.
11?
11 Stück ja. Das ist also relativ einmalig denke ich bundesweit.
Meistens sind es dann 2-3 Kollegen, die was machen oder es gibt einen Kollegen, der klassische Energietechnik macht und halt mal ein bisschen Solar und Wind mitmacht.
Bei uns sind es 11 Kollegen, die ausschließlich erneuerbare Energien machen.
Und ich bin halt seit 2004 vor Ort für regenerative Energiesysteme und bin der Sprecher für den Studiengang.
Was haben Sie denn für eine Ausbildung vorher gemacht, und inwiefern war das für Sie eine Selbstverständlichkeit diesen Weg zu gehen?
Na ich habe ganz klassisch Elektrotechnik studiert an einer „Elite-Hochschule“, KIT in Karlsruhe.
Damals hieß es noch technische Hochschule, ja ein ganz normales klassisches Elektrotechnikstudium.
Ich habe mich während dem Studium sehr aktiv auch in der Studentenschaft schon versucht einzubringen, um die Studienbedingungen zu verbessern und auch das Umweltproblem ist damals sehr schnell auf die Tagesordnung gekommen.
Wenn man Student ist, guckt man ja auch mal links und rechts.
Und mir war eigentlich relativ klar, dass ich dann auch gern in dem Bereich beruflich aktiv werden möchte.
Das war damals gar nicht so einfach, so Anfang der 90er Jahre.
Erneuerbare Energien kannten viele noch gar nicht.
Man hat mir mal ein Solarmodul geklaut, dann bin ich zur Polizei und habe gesagt, mir ist ein Photovoltaikmodul gestohlen worden.
Und dann der Polizist, was ist denn das?
Da hatte ich ein Foto dabei.
Ach ja ich glaube so was habe ich auch schon mal gesehen.
Also das waren die Zeiten damals und ich habe halt dann meine Abschlussarbeit mit Solar- und Windenergie schon gemacht.
Und habe dann versucht, auch in dem Bereich zu bleiben.
Habe in Berlin promoviert im Bereich Photovoltaik.
Hatte dort einen sehr guten Doktorvater, einer der wenigen, die damals überhaupt was im erneuerbaren Bereich gemacht haben.
Und nach fünf Jahren hier in Berlin bin ich dann nach Spanien ans Deutsche Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt gegangen, wo wir dann Solarkraftwerkstechnik gemacht haben.
In Spanien?
In Spanien ja.
Welcher Standort ist das da?
Südspanien, Almería In Andalusien ist das.
Gibt es auch unangenehmere Standorte nehme ich an?
Ja, also es ist irgendwie ganz nett.
Aber das ist ja ein Solarzentrum diese Region in Spanien, wo relativ große Photovoltaikanlagen in Betrieb sind, soweit ich weiß, stimmt das?
Bedingt ja.
Bedingt?
Also seit den 70er Jahren gibt es dort eine Forschungseinrichtung, das war eine deutsch-spanische Kooperation.
Wir hatten ja mal die Ölkrisen in Deutschland und weltweit und dann hat man sich Gedanken gemacht damals schon, man braucht Alternativen und hat dann auf erneuerbare Energien gesetzt.
Das war so die erste Welle.
Dann wurde das Öl wieder billig und dann hat man das alles wieder vergessen.
Aber seit der Zeit gibt es diese Forschungseinrichtung.
Und diese deutsch-spanische Forschungseinrichtung, die wurde lange Jahre dann auch noch fortgeführt und in den 90er Jahren wie gesagt war ich dann auch dort vor Ort.
Es ist dann eine Kooperation zwischen dem Deutschen Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt, die auch eine Energieabteilung haben und der spanischen Forschungseinrichtung dort CIEMAT.
Das war also der Forschungsbereich.
Was Sie jetzt angesprochen haben sind Industrieanlagen.
Also, als ich hingekommen bin, gab es noch relativ wenig.
Man hat dann in Spanien ein bisschen versucht auch, den deutschen Weg vielleicht auch nachzuzeichnen mit der Energiewende.
Hat dort dann Ende der 90er Jahre recht gute Förderbedingungen gemacht für erneuerbare Energien.
Und dann sind in der Folgezeit einige Anlagen entstanden.
Das hat man aber dann, als die Wirtschaftskrise in Spanien angefangen hat, ein paar Jahre später wieder komplett eingestellt.
Also deswegen ist das so ein bisschen ein Strohfeuer gewesen.
Man kann heute die Anlagen noch sehen.
Aber Spanien ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt mehr das Vorzeigeland für den Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien.
Schade eigentlich.
Sonne genug haben sie und billig wäre es auch.
Will man meinen.
Na gut, das mag sich ja noch ändern.
Bevor wir gleich nochmal aufs Thema kommen, was ich auch noch ganz interessant finde, ist, Sie haben sich ja auch gleich auf YouTube noch einen eigenen Kanal zugelegt, der noch zusätzlich mit bespielt wird.
Ist das so eine Aktivität im Kontext der Uni oder ist das eigentlich mehr so eine private Aktivität?
So teils teils.
Wir hatten also ein kleines Projekt in der Uni, wo wir das mal angefangen haben.
Da haben wir ein paar Videos gedreht und da ist jetzt aber kein Geld mehr da.
Und ich mache das eigentlich jetzt privat weiter, also so ein bisschen als Hobby.
Weil wenn man in der Forschung tätig ist und eigentlich aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht sieht, was man für die Energiewende, für den Klimaschutz eigentlich machen müsste und wenn man sieht, was draußen passiert und was die Politik so macht, dann kann man einfach nur sagen, Herr schmeiß Hirn vom Himmel, da muss irgendwas passieren.
Und dann hat man einfach auch den Drang, vielleicht einfach die Öffentlichkeit ein bisschen aufzuklären.
Und das ist vielleicht auch der Hintergrund, warum ich einfach versuche, auch hier im Internet ein bisschen was zu bringen.
Einfach allgemein verständliche Informationen.
Ich meine, unsere Studenten sind aufgeklärt, die wissen alle Bescheid.
Aber was hilft das, wenn dann 95% draußen und auch vor allem die Politik dann nicht so wirklich den Durchblick hat und deswegen auch viele Fehlentscheidungen in Deutschland leider stattfinden.
Ja, was sind so Ihre Erfahrungen, was für Leute erreicht man darüber?
Oder baut es erst mal nur so ein Netzwerk von likeminded people auf?
Am Anfang sicherlich ja, mittlerweile läuft der Kanal ganz gut.
Mein letztes Video hat über 60.000 Klicks gekriegt.
Das ist glaube ich für den Wissenschaftsbereich ganz ordentlich.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und das ist natürlich dann querbeet.
Also die Videos sind auch so angelegt, dass man als Nichtstudent die verstehen kann.
Und deswegen haben wir auch da eine Zuschauerschaft.
Man sieht es an den Kommentaren so ein bisschen.
Der letzet zu Elektromobilität hatte dann auch 600 Kommentare.
Und dann sieht man auch an den Kommentaren, dass die aus allen Bereichen der Gesellschaft auch kommen.
Dann nähern wir uns mal diesem Begriff der Energiewende.
Das ist ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wann der so geboren wurde.
Also ist ja ein politischer Begriff zunächst einmal.
Genau.
Der wurde so aufgelegt mit, das suggeriert ja dann erst mal so, alles wird anders.
Die Urheberschaft geht glaube ich irgendwie so in die 80er Jahre zurück.
Aber damals hat den Begriff keiner ernst gemeint.
Und richtig wiedergeboren oder von der Politik vereinnahmt wurde der Begriff dann mit dem Kernenergieausstieg.
Also das heißt Wende ist ja immer so ein Begriff, den man gerne in der Politik verwendet.
Und dann brauchte man irgendwie ein Schlagwort, und dann gab es halt plötzlich die Energiewende.
Eigentlich mit dem Unglück in Fukushima ist der dann wirklich populär geworden.
Wie gesagt, gegeben hat es den schon vorher im Wissenschaftsbereich, aber wirklich der Bevölkerung als populäres Wort dann seit Fukushima.
Ja und wenn auch die CDU ihn sozusagen in den Mund nimmt, dann gibt es eigentlich niemanden mehr, der ihn nicht mehr führt.
In den 80er Jahren war ja sozusagen das Aufkommen der Grünen im Prinzip so, das hat es ja alles eingeleitet.
Hat ja im Prinzip diese aufkommenden Debatte, sowohl um Frieden als auch um die Umwelt, mit begleitet.
Es gab ja so frühe Ereignisse, Baumsterben etc., wo man so gemerkt hat, wie in der Gesellschaft überhaupt erst mal so ein Verständnis für die Problematik mit so, was wir machen ist unter Umständen ein bisschen kontraproduktiv für die Welt.
Dann konnte man es halt an Bäumen erst mal sehr gut festmachen.
Während ja so der Klimawandel, der sicherlich zu diesem Zeitpunkt auch schon von vereinzelten Wissenschaftlern diskutiert wurde, noch lange nicht in der Öffentlichkeit so präsent war.
Das hat sich dann für meinen Geschmack so im Laufe der 90er Jahre erst so richtig gewandelt.
Ja, na wir hatten ja auch schon früher Umweltprobleme, die Smog-Problematik zum Beispiel.
Wir hatten ja durchaus auch schon mal gesperrte Innenstädte, das ist ja gar kein neues Problem.
Oh ja richtig.
Genau.
Und die Ölkrise, die schon erwähnt wurde.
Die Ölkrise war jetzt kein Umweltproblem, aber es war einfach auch ein finanzielles Problem.
Also was die Volkswirtschaft dann sehr hart getroffen hat.
Also im Energiebereich gab es ja schon öfter solche einschneidenden Ergebnisse.
Zu meiner Kindheit dann Tschernobyl, was also die Leute dann auch sehr stark geprägt hat.
Wir haben ja heute noch Gebiete in Bayern, wo Sie immer noch kein Wildschwein essen können, weil das immer noch radioaktiv belastet ist.
Also was sich bis heute durchzieht.
Und das sind einfach verschiedene Sachen.
Damals wurde die Anti-AKW-Bewegung sicherlich relativ groß.
Und dann haben wir, na klar die Umweltproblematik geht jüngst mit dem Klimawandel.
Eigentlich ist das in der Wissenschaft schon auch seit den 90er Jahren bekannt.
Populär wurde das wahrscheinlich auch zu der Zeit, als Al Gore den Friedensnobelpreis gekriegt hat.
Mit dem Film „Die unbequeme Wahrheit“, dann auch später noch den Oskar.
Und das waren so die Sachen, wo das eigentlich so ins öffentliche Bewusstsein reingelangt ist.
Wo man dann auch gedacht hat, oh ja jetzt haben die Leute verstanden, wo die richtige Problematik ist und man tut was.
Leider ist es immer so, dass man sich auch sehr schnell dran gewöhnt.
Das heißt also erst war der Schock ganz groß.
Wir haben jetzt irgendwie eine Klimaveränderungen, die katastrophal ist.
Und mittlerweile hat man so den Eindruck, dass man sich so dran gewöhnt hat und sagt, ja das kommt, können wir eh nichts gegen tun.
Das ist immer so ein bisschen wie mit dem Rauchen, weiß man auch, dass man irgendwann an Krebs stirbt.
Und das hat irgendwie den gleichen Gewöhnungseffekt mittlerweile dann auch bei der Energiewende und beim Klimaschutz gegeben.
Ja, wobei wenn es dann um einzelne Personen geht, ist es was anderes, als wenn es irgendwie um alle geht.
Klar.
Was ist denn dann geschehen?
Also sagen wir einfach mal, der Zeitpunkt, wo Angela Merkel dann eingesehen hat, dass eine Verlängerung der Laufzeiten von Atomkraftwerken jetzt auch nicht unbedingt die Antwort ist.
Weil das war ja im Prinzip schon bisschen die These mit, okay wir CO2-Problem.
Atomkraftwerke hauen ja kein CO2 raus, alles super.
Nur dass natürlich die Problematik der Atomenergie auch eine ganz eigene Dimension hat, die von der Klimafrage zunächst einmal entkoppelt werden sollte.
Aber eben auch nicht fortführbar war.
Das heißt man war in dem Moment sozusagen in der Pflicht, mehr zu tun als nur Atomkraftwerke weiter zu betreiben.
Ja. Das Timing war einfach ungünstig.
Bei der Kernenergie, man baut das gerne auf als Klimaschutztechnologie.
Man kann sehen in Deutschland hat die Kernenergie nie mehr als gut 10% des gesamten Energiebedarfs gedeckt.
Man muss ja nicht nur auf Strom gucken, wir müssen auch die Wärme, den Verkehr, also alle Bereiche sehen.
Wenn wir den gesamten Energiebedarf haben, den wir in Deutschland haben, dann war die Kernenergie schon immer einstellig vom Prozentbereich.
Also da einen enormen Klimaschutzvorteil abzuleiten, wenn wir wissen, dass wir komplett CO2-frei werden müssen, 100% einsparen, dann ist es ja ganz nett, wenn die Kernenergie 8% oder so was deckt, aber die Lösung für das Problem ist es ja nicht wirklich.
Also eine Verzehnfachung der Kernenergie hätte sich sowieso keiner in Deutschland vorstellen können. Also war die Kernenergie sowieso noch nie die Lösung für das Klimaproblem.
Das wird immer gerne so dargestellt.
Weltweit sind wir jetzt bei unter 5% Anteil der Kernenergie.
Also für den Klimaschutz ist die absolut irrelevant.
Aber das Timing in Deutschland war natürlich relativ ungünstig.
Wir hatten ja schon mal unter rot-grün den Ausstiegsbeschluss.
Wir hatten ja eine lange Zeit die anti-AKW-Diskussion, was von Tschernobyl ausgehend ist.
Grünes Thema gewesen, bei rot-grün hat man dann mit der Industrie einen einvernehmlichen Ausstieg beschlossen.
Und hatte eigentlich gehofft, dass das gesellschaftlich politisch dann erledigt ist.
Ich hatte 2-3 Jahre vor Tschernobyl mal eine Podiumsdiskussion, da waren dann Vertreter von großen Energiekonzernen mit auf der Bühne.
Und ich habe im Vorgespräch da mal gefragt, naja jetzt unter rot-grün gab es ja einen Ausstiegsbeschluss, genau wie sieht denn jetzt so die Strategie des Energiekonzerns aus?
Was will man denn machen?
Ja die Strategie ist ganz einfach, nach rot-grün kommt schwarz-gelb und dann machen wir alles wieder rückgängig.
Hat er mir so ganz knallhart ins Gesicht gesagt, also nicht auf der Bühne, sondern im Vieraugengespräch.
Und da habe ich gesagt, okay das ist also auch eine Position.
Und dann sieht man, so hat man gearbeitet.
Das heißt man hat zwar unter rot-grün diesen Vertrag unterschrieben, aber hat nie wirklich dran geglaubt und hat gesagt, okay bei schwarz-gelb machen wir ein bisschen Seelenmassage und machen mal ein paar nette Essen für die Abgeordneten.
Und irgendwann sind die weichgekocht und dann gibt es wieder einen Rückgang in dem Bereich.
Und genauso ist es dann halt auch gekommen.
Das heißt also schwarz-gelb hat dann den Ausstieg aus dem Ausstieg beschlossen.
Man sollte die Kernkraftwerke 40-50 Jahre länger laufen lassen.
Und kurz knappes halbes Jahr nachdem man das beschlossen hat und gesagt hat, deutsche Kernkraftwerke und westliche Kernkraftwerke sind sicher.
War ja immer die Frage, wir hatten ja vorher Tschernobyl, das ist ja unsicher.
Da sagt man, ja das ist ja ein russisches Atomkraftwerk.
Die westlichen Atomkraftwerke sind ja ganz anders, die sind für alle Eventualitäten ausgelegt und geplant.
Es kann nie irgendwas passieren.
Und just kurz darauf in einem genau baugleichen oder bauähnlichen Kraftwerk in Japan passiert halt ein Unglück, was also dann natürlich die ganze komplette Glaubwürdigkeit zerstört hat.
Und wir hatten da ja einen Höhenflug der Grünen mit Umfragewerten von über 20%.
Und ich erinnere mich an ein Interview, was mir noch im Gedächtnis geblieben ist, wo der Herr Lindner in einem Interview gesagt hat, man müsste eigentlich schneller aus der Kernenergie aussteigen als die Grünen das jetzt vorgeschlagen haben.
Und das war so die Zeit, mehrere Tage nach Fukushima, wo man also versucht hat, die Politik versucht momentan so ein bisschen die Felle zu retten.
Und einfach den massiven Stimmenverlust zu vermeiden.
Also das was jetzt mit der AfD im Prinzip passiert ist, ist damals sozusagen im Umweltbereich Richtung Grünen abdiffundiert.
Mit dem Sieg in Baden-Württemberg, der sicherlich auch …
Genau grüner Ministerpräsident im schwarzen Land, absolut undenkbar vorher gewesen.
Und deswegen hat man halt einfach auch versucht, das rückgängig zu machen und relativ schnell dann wieder die Fehler, die man dann doch eingesehen hat, zu korrigieren.
Ohne dass natürlich dann, also man hat dann einfach auf dem Papier ein Ausstiegsdatum gemacht, dann aber auch kein Konzept entwickelt, wie man da wirklich hingeht oder so.
Damit war das Thema erst mal erledigt.
Die Umfragewerte haben sich ja wieder stabilisiert.
Und wenn das dann passt, dann braucht man als Politik ja nicht wirklich nachlegen.
Ja so sieht es leider oft aus.
Aber schauen wir doch mal, was sozusagen die Realität eigentlich ist.
Wie nutzen und wie beziehen wir die Energie in Deutschland derzeit oder vielleicht nicht unbedingt Bestandsaufnahme heute, sondern eben so zu diesem gefühlten Stichtag mit, jetzt müssen wir es mal anders machen und selbst Atomkraftwerke werden uns nicht helfen.
Was war denn so die Realität in Deutschland zu dem Zeitpunkt?
Na gut, müssen wir ein bisschen noch zurückgehen.
Zu Fukushima-Zeiten hatten wir ja schon unter rot-grün ein bisschen die Energiewende begonnen.
Aber wenn wir jetzt mal in die 90er Jahre zurückgehen, also Anfang der 90er Jahre hatten wir einen erneuerbaren Anteil von 2%.
Das heißt also die Energieversorgung wurde durch ein bisschen Kernenergie und dann im wesentlichen durch Öl, Kohle und Gas gedeckt.
Dann muss man wissen, dass Deutschland ja gar kein Öl und kein Gas hat.
Also was ja auch irgendwo vielleicht als Strategie nicht so wirklich sinnvoll ist, da eine Energieversorgung drauf auszubauen.
Deutschland hat in Spitzenzeiten, ich glaube 2008/09 für 100 Milliarden Euro Öl und Gas importiert.
Jetzt ist der Ölpreis ja ein bisschen gefallen.
Wir waren jetzt letztes Jahr ungefähr bei 60 Milliarden.
Aber das heißt unsere Energieversorgung basiert im Wesentlichen auf Import von Energieträgern, Öl, Kohle und Gas.
Und das aus Ländern, sage ich mal, wo man vielleicht nicht unbedingt von den Herrschern dort ein gebrauchtes Auto kaufen würde.
Also insofern das ist derzeit unsere Energieversorgung.
Wird überhaupt nicht diskutiert.
Also ich finde das immer faszinierend, wir reden immer über die Kosten der Energiewende, dass wir da irgendwie jeden Cent umdrehen müssen.
Dass wir 20 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr ausgeben, was ja ungeheuer viel ist und ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken überweisen wir 60 Milliarden Euro an den Herrn Putin, an die Kollegen dann im Nahen Osten.
Und ja gut die Saudis kaufen vielleicht dann irgendwann mal deutsche Panzer dafür.
Aber das ist ja sage ich mal auch keine nachhaltige Energiepolitik, wenn wir einfach mal den Umweltaspekt rauslassen.
Also wenn man die Energiewende hier vor Ort betreiben würde, würde das Geld ja im Land bleiben, man könnte auch viel mehr machen.
Aber das wird auch nicht diskutiert.
Das sind halt einfach die alten Strukturen.
Die entsprechenden Vertreter der Energiekonzerne, sei es Öl, Kohle, Gas, sind da auch relativ mächtig und relativ gut vernetzt.
Deswegen hat sich da auch lange Zeit nichts geändert und auch nicht beim Verständnis der Energiekonzerne.
Wie wir das an dem Beispiel gesehen haben bei der Kernenergie.
Was waren denn die 2% regenerativen Energien?
Was hat denn am Anfang als erstes durchgeschlagen?
Durchgeschlagen hat es nicht.
Es war die Wasserkraft, die erste Art der Stromerzeugung in Deutschland war ja die Wasserkraft.
Die war damals ja relativ verlässlich.
So eine Dampfmaschine oder wie man damals Strom erzeugt hat, war ja doch eher so ein technisches Wagnis.
Also wenn man irgendwie vor gut 100 Jahren das gesehen hat, ein Wasserrad, das läuft halt rund und da konnte man halt relativ zuverlässig Strom erzeugen.
Wir hatten auch mal einen erneuerbaren Anteil, der deutlich höher war.
Wenn wir also 100 Jahre zurückdenken, der schon relativ groß war durch die Wasserkraft insgesamt.
Und was wir in den 90er Jahren noch hatten waren halt im Prinzip historische Wasserkraftwerke.
Sonst eigentlich nicht wirklich was.
Aber dann kam ja relativ schnell Bewegung in die ganze Geschichte.
Es wurde mit Wind und Solar relativ früh experimentiert.
Ich denke mal, das waren so die Folgen von Tschernobyl.
Also wir hatten dann ja, glaube 87 war ja Tschernobyl, in der Folge versuchte man doch auch, Alternativen zur Kernenergie zu entwickeln.
Es gab so ein bisschen eine Graswurzelbewegung für Wind und Photovoltaik.
Und in den 90er Jahren gab es so ein bisschen, man redet ja immer so von der Pizza Connection, wenn man so parteiübergreifende Sachen hat.
Man hat dann ein Gesetz beschlossen, das Stromeinspeisegesetz hieß es damals.
Also vor war es ja gar nicht möglich mit einer Photovoltaik- oder Windkraftanlage überhaupt Strom ins Netz einzuspeisen.
Ich konnte das zwar irgendwo auf irgendwie auf einer Batterie irgendwo auf dem Hof als Inselnetzanlage machen, aber es gar nicht zulässig, überhaupt Strom einzuspeisen.
Und dann hat man ein relativ einfaches Gesetz beschlossen, wow man gesagt hat, also a) man darf einspeisen und b) man kriegt sogar Geld dafür.
Und das war eigentlich eine relativ große Revolution.
Und das hat dazu geführt, dass dann auch viele da ein Geschäftsmodell entwickelt haben.
Am Anfang, also wie gesagt parteiübergreifend ging das ja durch.
Also das heißt man hat dann auch aus klassischen, also auf CDU-Seite gesagt, ja das kann man ja machen, das ist ein bisschen, lass die mal ein bisschen spielen, so nach dem Motto nicht.
Das werden ja homöopathische Dosen bleiben.
Das heißt Solar- und Windenergie werden ja nie im Leben wettbewerbswirtschaftlich werden.
Und dann hat man schon gesehen, dass dann da doch einiges bewegt wurde.
Vor allem im Windbereich hat man dann Anlagen entwickelt, die mit der Vergütung, die war ein bisschen höher als marktüblich, aber auch nicht so exorbitant hoch, doch schon irgendwann hingekommen ist.
Und dann hat sich einfach dieser Markt relativ dynamisch entwickelt.
Unter rot-grün hat man die Bedingungen noch mal dann verbessert, aber die Wurzeln wurden eigentlich schon vorher gelegt durch die Stromeinspeisegesetz, was parteiübergreifend beschlossen wurde.
91 war das.
Müsste sein ja.
Gerade mal nachgeschlagen.
Und das bezieht sich ja dann nur auf Strom.
Genau.
So. Wenn man jetzt sozusagen den Energiebedarf Deutschlands damals dann genommen hat, welchen Anteil hat Strom letzten Endes eigentlich an dem gesamten Energiebedarf?
Oder lässt sich das überhaupt so gegen rechnen?
Sind das einfach komplett getrennte Bereiche, die man für sich betrachten muss?
Es gibt immer unterschiedliche Rechnungen, die man hat.
Also im Energiebereich reden wir von der Primärenergie.
Das ist die Energie, die man am Anfang verwenden muss, zum Beispiel ins Kraftwerk schmeißen.
Also das wäre die rohe Kohle oder das Uran.
Andere reden von der Endenergie, das wäre also der Strom, der hinten rauskommt.
Und je nachdem was man betrachtet, ist der Strombereich der größte oder halt ein kleinerer.
Also im Bereich der Primärenergie ist der Strombereich mit Abstand der größte Bereich der Energienutzung.
Weil die Kraftwerkswirkungsgrade ja relativ schlecht sind.
Also ein Kernkraftwerk fährt mit 30% Wirkungsgrad, 70% jage ich dann durch den Kühlturm und die Energie muss ich auch mit berücksichtigen, wenn ich diese Energie dann beim Primärenergiebedarf mit berücksichtige, ist der Anteil am größten.
Lass ich diese Abwärme, diese Verluste mit raus und guck mir die Endenergie an, dann ist der Wärmebereich der größte.
Also deswegen sieht man auch sehr unterschiedliche Statistiken.
Eigentlich müsste man für den Klimaschutz vielleicht eher die CO2-Bilanz sich anschauen.
Und da ist auch der Strombereich am schlimmsten.
Alleine 40% der deutschen CO2-Emissionen kommen aus der Kohleverstromung.
Das heißt da liegt also wirklich der Hase oder das Hauptproblem.
Ja CO2-Bereich 20% kommen aus dem Verkehr oder etwas mehr und dann aus der Wärme auch noch.
Aber der Strombereich, wenn ich den Klimaschutz anpacken will, ist der größte.
Aber ich darf die andern nicht vergessen.
Also selbst wenn ich diesen Strombereich komplett CO2-neutral habe, dann habe ich immer noch knapp 50% CO2-Emissionen übrig, die dann aus dem Verkehr und Wärme kommen.
Das heißt also, wenn ich die Energiewende andenke, dann muss ich alle drei großen Bereiche sehen Strom, Verkehr und Wärme.
Im Strombereich haben wir zumindest mal angefangen.
Also da haben wir wenigstens Ideen.
Im Verkehrsbereich hat man zwischendurch mal versucht, ein bisschen Biotreibstoffe zu machen, so alibimäßig.
Ansonsten ist der Verkehrsbereich so das absolute Sorgenkind momentan.
Da steigen die Treibhausgasemissionen sogar an.
Und im Wärmebereich da da tut sich was, aber auch sehr sehr langsam.
Auch da hat man sehr große Widerstände aus der Immobilienwirtschaft und das ist natürlich auch da immer nicht ganz einfach was durchzusetzen.
Widerstände, entsprechende technische Upgrades vorzunehmen.
Ja bis hin dazu, es gab jetzt mal den Vorstoß.
Also wir wissen, dass die Elektromobilität kommen wird.
Also wenn wir nach China gucken, die drücken das mit einer Brachialgewalt durch.
Also wenn die Deutschen das nicht machen, dann werden das die Chinesen machen und dann wird das irgendwann wie mit den Smartphones sein.
Es wird dann keine deutschen Autos mehr geben, es wird nur noch chinesische Elektroautos geben.
Ein Elektroauto ist wesentlich einfacher, Sie brauchen viel viel weniger Teile.
Momentan ist es noch teurer, weil die Batterie teuer ist.
Aber da sehen wir Kostensenkungen von 1% pro Monat bei den Batterien.
Also da verfallen die Preise enorm schnell und wir werden in fünf Jahren es nicht mehr sehen, dass ein vergleichbarer Verbrenner billiger ist als ein Elektroauto.
In fünf Jahren?
In fünf Jahren.
Und das heißt diese Technologie wird mit Brachialgewalt kommen.
Es gibt weitere Vorteile, einfach nur die Stickoxidproblematik, brauchen wir gar nicht anfangen.
Aber es macht einfach auch mehr Spaß, mit einem Elektroauto zu fahren.
Das heißt Sie haben ein Auto, was umweltfreundlicher ist, was einfach mehr Spaß macht und was dann auch noch billiger ist, wer soll da noch einen Verbrenner kaufen?
Also das Thema ist dann irgendwann durch.
Die Chinesen werden das machen, die investieren jetzt die nächsten drei Jahre über 10 Milliarden Euro in Ladeinfrastruktur.
Die wollen 4 Million Schnellladestation bauen im eigenen Land.
In Deutschland hat man gesagt, hurra, wir haben eine Million Elektroautos auf der Straße und tun halt nichts dafür.
Insofern das wird da nicht wirklich funktionieren.
Aber wir waren ja bei der Immobilienwirtschaft.
Also langer Bogen, es gab man den Vorstoß, dass man gesagt hat, die Elektromobilität wird kommen.
Und wir machen jetzt eine Verordnung, dass an jedem Stellplatz, der in der Tiefgarage von so einem Neubau ist, eine Steckdose gebracht wird.
Vorgeschrieben ist, dass man die da baut.
Das wäre sehr sinnvoll, weil Nachrüsten ist immer teurer, als wenn Sie das mit einbauen.
Und sowas wurde dann von der Immobilienwirtschaft komplett abgewürgt, weil man möchte die Kosten der Gebäude nicht ins Unermessliche treiben.
Und das zeigt eigentlich wie absurd das ist.
Also wir reden da über ein paar tausend Euro für Steckdosen in der Tiefgarage, was dann vielleicht im Promillebereich der Gebäudekosten sind.
Was dann für die Energiewende enorme Kosten spart.
Weil wenn Sie das Anfang nachzurüsten, dann Elektriker dann irgendwelche Kabel durchs Haus ziehen, das wird dann zehnmal so teuer.
Das heißt also, wenn wir es von Anfang an richtig machen, kann man also wahnsinnig viel Geld auch bei der Energiewende sparen.
Aber es gibt einfach diese Widerstände, die solche ganz banalen Ansätze, wie Steckdosen an Parkplätzen, schon am Anfang im Keim ersticken.
Bleiben wir mal bei der Elektromobilität.
Das ist ja auch derzeit wirklich so ein bisschen das am heißesten diskutierte Feld.
Die Aussage, in fünf Jahren wird das alles anders sein, habe ich hier und da schon mal gelesen.
Man erfährt auch viele andere Einschätzungen, dass das ja alles nicht so schnell gehen würde und das wäre ja alles, man müsste das sehr langfristig machen und das wäre auch noch alles viel zu teuer derzeit.
Andere Argumente sind, da gibt’s ja gar nicht genug Batterie, also gibt’s gar nicht genug Rohstoffe für die Batterien, um all diese Batterien, die gebraucht werden würden, um auf diese Zahlen zu kommen, die dann überhaupt herzustellen.
Ganz abgesehen von dem Energiebedarf, um die dann überhaupt erst mal alle urbar zu machen.
Das ist ja so sagen wir mal derzeit, was viele Leute auch verwirrt in dieser ganzen Debatte und zu unterschiedlichen Einschätzungen darüber bringt, wie realistisch dieser Trend tatsächlich ist.
Was sagen Sie dazu?
Naja auch hier müssen wir mal schauen, wer diejenigen sind, die da bisschen mauern thematisch.
Und wie hat die deutsche Automobilindustrie momentan das Feld versucht aufzurollen, ganz klar mit dem Diesel.
Also wie war die Strategie der Automobilkonzerne?
Wir machen den Diesel, der ist jetzt zwar lange Zeit dreckig, also machen wir clean Diesel, was dabei rausgekommen ist, haben wir ja in den USA gesehen.
Und das war dann die Strategie, dann auch den Klimaschutz zu machen.
Diesel ist ja angeblich besser, hat man dann aber auch nicht mehr hingekriegt.
Also hat man dann in den Testzyklen so lange rumgedoktert.
Mittlerweile ist es ja so, dass man auf dem Prüfstand 40% weniger Spritverbrauch hat als in der realen Praxis.
Und damit hat man auf dem Papier natürlich auch 40% CO2 eingespart.
Das hilft uns in der realen Praxis allerdings nicht viel, deswegen steigen da die CO2-Emissionen an.
Das heißt also, dass die Strategie, die man gehabt hat, sich mit immer mehr durchmogeln, das hat einfach gezeigt, es funktioniert irgendwo nicht.
Warum macht das die deutsche Automobilindustrie?
Es gibt halt ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal, das die deutsche Automobilindustrie hat, das sind einfach die Motorentechnik.
Da ist Deutschland weltweit führend und deswegen kann man auch Autos mit tollen Motoren für viel mehr Geld verkaufen als irgendwelche Konkurrenten aus Asien zum Beispiel anbieten.
So wenn jetzt allerdings ein Elektroauto kommt, da ist kein Motor mehr drin, zumindest mal kein Verbrennungsmotor.
Da ist ein ganz banaler Elektromotor drin und da wickle ich ein bisschen Kupfer um den Kern und fertig.
Also das kann jeder.
Das gab es auch schon vor 100 Jahren, das ist jetzt nichts Neues.
Genau da ist kein Know-how mehr dabei.
Wurde auch in Oberschöneweide gebaut, direkt bei Ihnen nebenan war glaube ich die erste Elektromotorenfabrik.
Genau, also ich meine, wir hatten ja schon mal Zeiten, wo in New York mehr Elektroautos auf der Straße waren als Verbrennungsautos.
Also das ist schon gut 100 Jahre her.
Da waren natürlich die Stückzahlen viel viel kleiner.
Also das war nach der Kutsche, da kam also erst mal das Elektroauto, dann hat sich der Verbrenner durchgesetzt.
Ursache war damals, dass der Anlasser erfunden wurde.
Vorher war der Verbrenner ja total unbeliebt, man musste ja mit der Kurbel da den Motor starten.
Also für eine Frau unzumutbar und auch irgendwie den einen oder anderen Knochenbruch soll es da auch bei Männern gegeben haben.
Also insofern hat man da doch lieber die Finger von gelassen und ist halt mit den vermeintlich besseren Batterieautos durch die Gegend gefahren.
Mit dem Anlasser wurde das bequemer und da war ja das Reichweitenproblem bei der Batterie halt damals schon da und deswegen hat sich dann der Verbrenner überhaupt durchgesetzt.
Aber ja das hat Deutschland wie gesagt als Alleinstellungsmerkmal gehabt diese Motorentechnik, die fällt halt raus.
Das Know-how ist eigentlich in der Batterietechnik und die kommt aus Asien komplett.
Das heißt also hier hat man in Deutschland komplett verschlafen, auf den Trend der Zeit aufzuspringen und rechtzeitig die entsprechenden Assets dann sich zu sichern.
Das heißt wir bauen jetzt auch Elektroautos.
Das ist total einfach, da können sogar …
Also es gibt ein Startup in München, das Sion, das sind ein paar ehemalige Schüler, sage ich mal, oder Studenten, die im Prinzip jetzt ein Auto gebaut haben.
Die haben jetzt einfach über Crowdfunding Geld eingesammelt und die Teile kaufen die sich von Zulieferern und die haben jetzt ein Elektroauto entwickelt, was für unter 20.000 Euro verkauft werden soll.
Ist das das Modell mit den Solarpaneelen?
Genau, das ist das.
Die haben auch ein paar nette Ideen, Solarzellen oben drauf.
Ich will gar nicht jetzt irgendwie schlecht machen, es sind wirklich pfiffig tolle Leute, die das machen.
Aber wenn da jetzt ein großer Konzern 50 Ingenieure dransetzt, die 20 Jahre Erfahrung haben, dann kann man so was natürlich auch mit einer ganz anderen Dynamik auch entwickeln.
Und das passiert gerade in China.
Das heißt also, wenn ein deutsches Startup-Unternehmen so ein Auto für unter 20.000 bauen kann, dann wird ein chinesisches Unternehmen mit der entsprechenden Power dahinter, so was auch für 10-15.000 Euro hinkriegen.
Und das werden wir die nächsten Jahre einfach sehen.
Ich will da jetzt nicht zu tief reingehen, aber ist ja auch so, dass es durchaus Elektroautos gibt aus deutscher Manufaktur.
BMW hat da zumindest ein paar Modelle am Start.
Im Vergleich zu China ist das auch wieder lächerlich.
Also wir können mal zählen, Deutschland die Anzahl der Modelle, die es gibt, sind irgendwie einstellig oder vielleicht Anfang zweistellig.
In China gibt es glaube ich mittlerweile über 100 verschiedene Elektroauto-Modelle.
China führt jetzt auch die Elektroautoquote ein. Das heißt also ab 2019 müssen 10% aller Autos, die in China verkauft werden, elektrische sein.
China hat letztes Jahr über 20 Millionen Autos umgesetzt, das heißt also wir werden in China 2019 über 2 Millionen Neuzulassungen im Elektromobil-Bereich sehen.
Also das wir einfach mal so diese Dimension sehen, in Deutschland reden wir von 30.000 gerade.
Deswegen das ist einfach das Problem.
Das Geschäftsmodell der Großen lässt sich einfach nicht mehr übertragen auf die moderne Welt.
Also ein Elektroauto ist nicht nur sparsamer an Bauteilen, sondern ist auch sparsamer im Verschleiß.
Also Sie brauchen ja viel weniger Teile, keine Getriebe, keine Kupplung, keinen Auspuff und Sie brauchen auch nicht den Ölwechsel mehr jedes Jahr.
Also wir haben vor einem guten Jahr eine Studie rausgebracht zur Sektorkopplung, wie denn unsere Energieversorgung bezüglich Klimaschutz aussehen müsste.
Und kurze Zeit später hat mich dann der Verband der deutschen Schmierstoffe kontaktiert, wie wir denn die Rolle der Schmierstoffe in der Energiewende künftig sehen.
So einen Frage, die ich mir vorher gar nicht gestellt hatte.
Aber das hat mir eingeleuchtet, ja klar, wenn die Elektromobilität kommt, dann fällt ein ganz tolles Geschäft weg, nämlich der Ölwechsel.
Und dann kann man einfach mal hochrechnen, 40-45 Millionen Autos mal 5 Liter Öl mal jedes Jahr, also da kommt einiges an Öl und auch an Umsatz zusammen.
Das bricht komplett weg.
Also das ist also schon relativ spannend.
Dann natürlich auch das damit verbundene Werkstattgeschäft.
Also was müssen Sie beim Elektroauto machen?
Sie bremsen ja dann in der Regel auch nicht mehr mit Bremsen, sondern über Rekooperation über den Motor, also nicht mal den Bremsenverschleiß haben Sie.
Auspuff verrostet auch nicht mehr, weil gibt keinen.
Sie müssen den Pollenfilter wechseln.
Das ist das, was an Wartung noch übrig bleibt.
Wenn Sie einfach mal schauen, wenn Sie die Werkstattrechnung angucken.
Ich glaube, wenn man ein Auto in Einzelteilen kauft, dann kostet auch so ein VW Golf dann sicherlich 200.000 Euro danach.
Das heißt das war eigentlich das große Geschäft und dieses fällt eigentlich weg.
Das heißt das ist wie beim Tintenstrahldrucker, der Drucker war für umsonst und die Tinte war halt irgendwie irre teuer.
Da zahlen Sie bis zu 500 Euro für einen Liter Tinte, da wird also dann das Geschäft gemacht.
Und genauso war ein großer Teil des Geschäftsmodells halt auch dieses Werkstattgeschäft.
Und wenn das halt jetzt wegbricht durch die Elektromobilität, müssen sich die Konzerne halt einfach mal komplett neu sortieren.
Die haben noch gar keine Antwort darauf, wie ihr Geschäftsmodell in der Zukunft ist.
Also ein Auto, wo sie kaum mehr Know-how drin haben, mit einer Batterie, die sie aus China importieren.
Mit einem wegfallenden Werkstattgeschäft, das ist nicht so sonderlich attraktiv.
Und deswegen hat man zwar Autos gebaut, musste man ja auch, aber wenn Sie sich die Autos angucken, dann sind das alles so die klassischen Zweit- oder Drittwagen.
Also die Strategie, die man bis jetzt gefahren hat, war, dass man sagt, einen fetten SUV als Erstwagen, als Familienauto.
Und okay, wenn da die Frau mal oder Mann irgendwie mal zum Briefkasten fahren will und die Leute genug Geld haben, dann können sie sich dafür ja ein Elektroauto kaufen fürs gute Gewissen.
Und das war dann die Strategie, die die Konzerne auch lange Zeit gefahren haben und dann auch hochpreisige Elektroautos, nichts für den Massenmarkt.
Und da fehlt die Antwort.
Mittlerweile hat man erkannt, also wir haben das ja gesehen, Herr Müller von VW hat ja mittlerweile auch gesagt, die Dieselsubventionen sollte man überprüfen.
Weil einfach auch VW damit konfrontiert ist, mit den Elektroautoquoten jetzt aus China.
Das heißt will VW in China noch bestehen und China ist einer der größten Märkte für VW, dann müssen die entsprechende Elektroautozahlen liefern.
Und die müssen jetzt im Expresstempo im Prinzip das nachholen, was sie die letzten 10 Jahre versäumt haben.
Da ist bestimmt richtig Panik gerade.
Kann ich mir schon ganz gut vorstellen ja.
Also man versucht das noch.
Noch hat man ja die Finanzkraft, aber ich glaube man hat jetzt nur einen Schuss sozusagen.
Also man hat wahnsinnig viel Geld in den USA verbrannt mit dem CleanDiesel und den Strafzahlungen.
Jetzt muss man, jetzt werden ja 37 Milliarden Euro von VW in die Elektromobilität investiert.
Wenn das daneben geht, dann ist die Frage, ob es VW in 20 Jahren noch gibt.
Der Mobilitätsbereich besteht ja nicht nur aus PKW.
Ich denke mal, ein großer Teil des Schmutzes und des CO2 wird ja im LKW-Bereich erzeugt.
Ja, auch da kann man, also muss man auch wieder differenzieren, es gibt ja den Fernverkehr und den Nahverkehr.
Also gerade das Problem für die Städte ist ja der innerstädtische Verkehr.
Da reden wir über Transportwege von 100 Kilometers, das kann man wunderbar auch elektrisch abdecken.
Die Post hatte ja schon mal die Idee, das zu machen.
Hat dann vor einigen Jahren bei den großen deutschen Automobilherstellern nachgefragt, sie hätten doch gerne ein Elektroauto, die wollten nicht liefern.
Das heißt was hat die Post gemacht?
Also einer der größten Elektroautohersteller in Deutschland ist ja derzeit die Deutsche Post bzw. Streetscooter, was also ein Startup ist, wo die Deutsche Post beteiligt ist.
Und das zeigt eigentlich, wie absurd oder wie sträflich diese Sache angegangen ist.
Mittlerweile steigen die Konzerne ein, also ist jetzt auch, eine Tochter von Daimler hat jetzt auch einen LKW-Truck entwickelt, also einen 7,5-Tonner, der elektrisch fährt.
Tesla hat in den USA einen größeren vorgestellt, da bin ich ein bisschen skeptisch, weil die Batterie da doch enorm schwer und groß ist.
Aber ja, auf alle Fälle tut sich da was.
Und in China habe ich gehört, ich weiß nicht, ob es stimmt, dass mittlerweile jeder zweite Bus, der in China auf die Straße kommt, elektrisch fährt.
Also in Deutschland ist das ja immer noch so mit Tamtam, mal ein Vorzeigeobjekt, was dann irgendwie dann getestet und eingeführt werden soll.
Die Chinesen machen das einfach und deswegen wird das früher oder später auch einfach passieren und kommen.
Weil das natürlich, muss man einfach mal bei den Bussen dann einfach hier hinten den Auspuffbereich angucken, wie rußig und schwarz das auch immer alles ist.
Also das ist ja auch der Dreck und der Lärm vor allen Dingen von den Bussen, der in die Stadt reinkommt und den wird man raushaben wollen.
Und wenn das die Deutschen nicht machen, dann kommt das irgendwann aus China.
Zumal ja die Busse auch permanent in Betrieb sind, im Gegensatz zu PKWs, die halt im wesentlichen eigentlich nur rumstehen.
Klar, also einfach die Fahrleistung ganz anders.
Auch im Lieferverkehr, also wir reden bei einem Transport-Lkw auch mal schnell von 50.000 Kilometer, die im Jahr gefahren werden.
Da muss man sich als PKW-Fahrer schon anstrengen, um das hinzukriegen, das ist eher die Ausnahme.
Bei LKWs dann doch eher die Regel.
Es gibt so einen Verkehrsbereich, der für meinen Geschmack immer so ein bisschen übersehen wird.
Das ist die Schifffahrt.
Da muss man jetzt sicherlich unterscheiden, so Binnenschifffahrt und so touristische Angebote, das ist glaube ich jetzt kein wirklich großer Teil der Gesamtmobilität, aber was so global um den Planeten gefahren wird, das ist doch schon nicht ganz unerheblich.
Zumal diese großen Frachter und Transporter, die großen Containerschiffe jetzt auch nicht unbedingt gerade so mit der fortschrittlichsten Katalysatortechnik am Start sind.
Sondern eigentlich so ein bisschen den Abfall von der Ölproduktion verbrennen.
Ja die verbrennen den letzten Dreck, also mit dem Schwerstöl.
Von der Menge her sind wir da im unteren einstelligen Prozentbereich, was die Treibhausgase anbelangt, weil wir haben einfach hier in Deutschland schon 45 Millionen PKWs.
Also einfach die Stückzahl, was auf der Straße passiert, ist halt einfach ungleich größer.
Deswegen spielt der Schiffsverkehr nicht so eine große Rolle, was die CO2-Problematik anbelangt.
Was die Schadstoffe anbelangt, wenn so ein großes Kreuzfahrtschiff im Hamburger Hafen einläuft, ist das schon eine erhebliche Umweltbelastung.
Also da geht man natürlich jetzt mittlerweile dazu über, dass man die Schiffe dazu zwingt, dann zumindest mal den Motor auch mal auszumachen, wenn sie im Hafen liegen.
Das ist also immer der erste Schritt, früher sind die ja einfach durchgelaufen, um ihre Stromversorgung an Bord zu sichern, mit entsprechenden Abgasen.
Nur da ist wieder der Konkurrenzkampf zum Teil zwischen den Häfen dann da.
Und dann sagen die halt einfach, na wenn Hamburg das macht, dann fahr ich halt nach Rotterdam.
Und deswegen ist so was dann im internationalen Bereich schwer durchzusetzen, genauso beim Luftverkehr.
Also das ist ja auch ein großes Problem.
Also den Luftverkehr sehe ich noch kritischer als den Schiffsverkehr.
Weil wir da auch eine sehr schnell wachsende Dynamik dann haben.
Das wird ja auch von vielen gar nicht gesehen.
Hier in Berlin sehen wir ja auch die Diskussionen über die Flughäfen, ob Tegel offen bleiben soll oder ob der geschlossen sein sollte.
Da haben wir ja auch eine Volksabstimmung dazu gemacht.
Da war dann die Wärmeproblematik oder irgendwie die Frage, von wo fliege ich ab.
Aber der Klimaschutz hat da auch überhaupt gar keine Rolle gespielt.
Wenn beide Flughäfen offen sind und voll ausgelastet sind, dann wäre das nochmal eine erhebliche Zunahme des Luftverkehrs und damit auch ein deutliches Problem im Klimaschutz.
Weil im Luftverkehr fehlen uns momentan auch wirklich schnelle Antworten, wie man preisgünstig die Energiewende durchsetzt.
Das geht mit alternativen Treibstoffen, aber das würde das Fliegen doch deutlich teurer machen.
Und wenn ein Land das durchsetzt, dann wird halt der Flieger woanders betankt, das ist auch genauso ein Problem.
Was ist denn der Beitrag des Flugwesens?
International ist es auch relativ klein, wir sind noch im einstelligen Prozentbereich, aber das ist bei den persönlichen Emissionen relativ interessant.
Also ich lasse meine Studenten immer mal ausrechnen, wie groß der persönliche CO2-Rucksack ist, in dem ersten Semester, damit sie ein bisschen Gefühl für die Energie kriegen.
Und der Durchschnitt in Deutschland liegt bei 10 Tonnen Kohlendioxyd, die jeder Deutsche ausstößt.
Die Chinesen liegen bei gut der Hälfte pro Kopf.
Also dann wenn Sie nach den Entwicklungsländer gehen, Bangladesch, da sind Sie deutlich unter einer Tonne.
Nur mal so im Prinzip, dass man das vergleicht.
Es gibt auch Sünderländer wie Amerika, die also da Richtung 20 gehen.
Und die Studenten sind in der Regel immer etwas unter dem Durchschnitt.
Weil sie auch weniger Einkommen haben, vielleicht auch nicht so große Wohnungen, so 7-8 Tonnen.
Aber es gibt dann immer Studenten, die sich dann melden, ja ich hatte jetzt 25 Tonnen.
Meine Frage ist immer, wohin sind Sie geflogen?
Und dann ganz klar, ja nach Australien.
Das heißt wenn man einfach so sieht, wie da die persönliche CO2-Bilanz durch so einen Flug aus dem Lot gebracht werden kann, dann ist der Flugverkehr dann in Deutschland sicherlich schon relativ enorm.
Das taucht in den Zahlen meistens auch nicht unbedingt auf.
Weil also in der deutschen CO2-Bilanz natürlich nur das CO2 berücksichtigt wird, was in Deutschland anfällt.
Wenn ich jetzt als Deutscher nach Australien fliege und der Flieger wird in Sydney betankt, dann zählt das nicht in die deutsche CO2-Bilanz rein.
Aber wenn er in Deutschland betankt wird?
Ja, aber genau das ist dann doch eher die kleinere Mengen.
Klar das fällt mit rein.
Aber wenn ich halt einfach eine Weltreise mache, dann fallen ein Hauptteil der CO2-Emissionen außerhalb an.
Deswegen ist das also hier sicherlich für den Persönlichen schwierig.
Es ist schwer auch zu sagen, weil wie gesagt einiges outgesourct ist von diesen Treibhausgasen.
Und weltweit ist es zum Glück nicht so viel, weil einfach 90% der Weltbevölkerung sich einen Flug gar nicht leisten kann.
Deswegen fällt das noch nicht so ins Gewicht.
aber je billiger das Fliegen wird und je höher der Lebensstandard wird, desto größer wird das Problem.
Schauen wir uns doch mal den Wärmebereich an.
Jede Wohnung wird irgendwie beheizt, also hoffentlich.
Meistens aus Gas, hier im Osten Deutschlands war es lange Zeit noch die Kohle, die die Treppen hochgetragen wurde.
Es gibt die eine oder andere energiesparendere Methode.
Es gibt ein paar Passivhäuser und Niedrigenergiehäuser.
Wie entwickelt sich das da und welchen Beitrag kann der Bereich Wärme hier eigentlich leisten?
Naja wir wissen ja, wenn wir den Klimaschutz ernst meinen und das Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen, müssen wir ja eigentlich in 20 Jahren komplett CO2-neutral werden.
Das ist glaube ich den meisten gar nicht bewusst, welchen Zeitdruck wir haben, also auch für den Klimaschutz.
Das gilt für den Verkehr, das gilt für die Wärme und für den Strom.
Also auch im Wärmebereich müssen wir gucken, dass wir da vorankommen.
Wir haben eine energetische Gebäudesanierungsrate, so heißt das im Fachjargon.
Also das heißt im Prinzip, wie viele Gebäude wir im Jahr dämmen.
DAs liegt so bei einem guten Prozent.
Da kann man einfach drüber nachdenken, also ein Prozent Gebäudesanierungsrate bedeutet, in 100 Jahren haben wir alle Gebäude einmal durch.
Wenn wir eigentlich wissen, dass wir in 20 Jahren mit der Energiewende fertig sein müssen, um das Klima zu retten, geht das alles viel zu langsam.
Also das heißt wenn man das ernst meint, müsste man erst mal die Gebäudesanierung hoch bringen, das ist dann aber immer eine Kostenfrage.
Also Gebäude dämmen ist ja nicht ganz preiswert und da wird der schwarze Peter immer hin und her geschoben.
Die Immobilienwirtschaft sagt, wir können das nicht leisten, die Politik sagt, na so viel Subventionen können wir nicht aufbringen und deswegen tut sich da eigentlich seit Jahren nicht so sonderlich viel.
Im Neubaubereich haben wir ganz gute Sachen, aber was halt die Sanierung anbelangt, sieht es halt sehr schwierig aus.
Ansonsten ist die Hauptheizung, die wir in Deutschland haben derzeit Erdöl, also Heizöl und Erdgas.
Erdgas auf Platz 1 gefolgt von Erdöl, auch wieder zwei Energieträger, die wir in Deutschland gar nicht haben.
Ich weiß noch 2008, als die Ölpreise hoch waren, hat man sogar noch drüber diskutiert Heizkostenzuschüsse, also Subventionen für Heizöl in Deutschland einzuführen, damit sich die Leute das Heizen noch leisten können.
Also hohe Ölpreise werden wieder kommen, das heißt die Frage wird nicht zum letzten Mal gestellt sein.
Und deswegen sehen wir schon aus dem Grund müssen wir aus dem Öl und Gas raus.
Wenn ich klimaneutral werden will, darf ih auch kein Öl und Gas mehr verbrennen und dann brauchen wir eine Alternative.
Und das einzige, was uns in Deutschland da in großen Mengen einfällt, ist eigentlich, mit Strom zu heizen.
Das klingt jetzt erst mal paradox.
Hatten wir schon mal so, Nachtspeicherheizungen.
Genau, Strom war ja lange Zeit böse, das war dann also die Kohle- oder Atomheizung, über die Nachtspeicheröfen.
Jetzt arbeiten wir daran, dass möglichst hoffentlich in 20 Jahren der komplette Strom aus erneuerbaren kommt.
Also aus Solar- und Windenergie.
Und dann ist es natürlich eine CO2-neutrale Art zu heizen.
Aber natürlich auch nicht mit klassischen Nachtspeicheröfen.
Da war die Intension auch eine andere, jetzt nicht hier klimaneutrale Heizungen zu betreiben, sondern die Kraftwerke nachts besser auszulasten.
Da wollte man ja nachts einfach Strom verbrennen und hat sehr ineffiziente Heizungen eingebaut, um einfach den Strom, den ich nachts im Überschuss aus Atomkraftwerken habe, einfach los zu werden.
Diese Fragestellung haben wir nicht mehr.
Wir müssen möglichst effizient den Strom nutzen, deswegen werden wir das auch tunlichst nicht mehr mit solchen Direktheizungen machen, sondern es mit Wärmepumpen, die wesentlich effizienter den Strom in Wärme umsetzen können.
Da habe ich einen Hebel 1 zu 3, also ich kann aus einer Kilowattstunde Strom drei Kilowattstunden Wärme machen.
Weil die Wärmepumpe die Umgebungswärme noch mit nutzen kann.
Und das ist der Vorteil, deswegen sehen wir eigentlich als Konzept die Wärmepumpe mit erneuerbarem Strom und das möglichst in allen Häusern, wo das technisch möglich ist.
Um halt hier CO2-neutral zu werden und auch mit heimischen Energieträgern das Ganze zu versorgen.
Na in welchen ist es denn möglich?
Also die Wärmepumpe funktioniert technisch dann nur gut, wenn die Temperaturen nicht zu hoch sind.
Also wenn Sie einen Altbau haben und die Heizkörper darauf ausgelegt sind, mit 85 Grad Vorlauftemperatur zu arbeiten, da ist eine Wärmepumpe nicht ganz so optimal.
Das ist so ein Bereich, wo man sagen kann, okay da kann es sein, dass wir da noch andere Lösungen suchen müssen.
Eine Lösung könnte sein, dass wir da auch mit Gas arbeiten, aber das Gas jetzt nicht fossil, also aus Russland, beziehen, sondern uns aus Solar- und Windstrom herstellen.
Also über Elektrolyse kann ich dann erst mal Wasserstoff machen, den kann ich weiter zu Methan aufbereiten und damit dann Erdgas ersetzen.
Ist technisch möglich, nur eine Kostenfrage.
Oder …
Oder aus Biogasanlagen.
Biogas ja, nur da werden wir die Potenziale nicht haben, um die Gebäude zu …
Da gibt es einfach nicht genug Kuhdung, um alle Heizungen zu betreiben?
Genau. Da sind wir im einstelligen Prozentbereich und wir werden hier nicht 100% machen können.
Aber das ist schon Teil des Energiemixes auch?
Klar, Biomasse ist teil, Biogas ist da sicherlich dann eine Alternative, aber wie gesagt von den Potenzialen her, wenn wir wirklich sagen, wir wollen 100% umsetzen, dann ist das auch ein kleiner Nischenbereich.
Genauso wie die Biotreibstoffe, die wir derzeit haben, also Biodiesel oder E10, wir wissen 5% im Verkehrsbereich sind Biotreibstoffe, 95% sind fossil.
Und da kann man sich einfach ausrechnen, wenn ich 100% machen wollte, dann reichen die landwirtschaftlichen Flächen in Deutschland und Frankreich nicht aus, um die Treibstoffe dann herzustellen.
Okay, aber es gibt die Möglichkeit, das Gas, was in Gasbrennern verbrennt, auch durch Elektrolyse herzustellen.
Man kann das ersetzen, man braucht dafür aber natürlich viel viel mehr Strom aus erneuerbaren Energien, als wenn ich die Wärmepumpe betreibe.
Das heißt die Kröte, die ich schlucken muss, dass wir dann dreimal so viele Windkraftanlagen für die Gasherstellung und für die Wärmepumpe.
Weil da so viele Verluste in dem Zusammenhang sind?
Genau, wir haben einfach mehr Verluste und nicht Hebel Faktor 3 durch die Nutzung der Umgebungswärme, die die Wärmepumpe mit verwenden kann.
Finde ich ganz interessant, vielleicht können wir da nochmal im Detail darauf eingehen.
Was macht denn diese Wärmepumpe genau?
Das ist im Prinzip ein umgedrehter Kühlschrank.
Also man hat ja einfach einen Kompressor, wenn Sie dann Luft zusammendrücken oder ein Gas, dann wird das warm, so wie bei der Luftpumpe, und wenn Sie es wieder ausdehnen lassen, wird es kalt.
Und deswegen ist das einfach ein Kompressor, der Strom dafür wird dann aus erneuerbaren Energien verwendet, der erst mal die Luft auf Druck bringt.
Und dann lässt man sie praktisch wieder abkühlen und über diese Druckerzeugung kriege ich dann halt entsprechend Wärme.
Und wenn das Ganze abgekühlt hat, dann ist es flüssig, ich muss es dann wieder verdampfen und für dieses Verdampfen auf ganz niedrigen Temperaturen kann ich die Umgebungswärme halt mit verwenden.
Das heißt also ich nehme die elektrische Energie für den Kompressor, muss aber vorher dann das Medium, was ich auf Druck mache, das muss ich halt erst verdampfen und deswegen da kann ich dann die Umgebungswärme mit einbeziehen.
Und da habe ich dann den Hebel, 2/3 der Wärme, die ich dann insgesamt im System habe, kommt halt für das Verdampfen von der Umgebungswärme und 1/3 für den Antrieb vom Kompressor aus dem Strom aus erneuerbaren und dadurch habe ich natürlich den Vorteil.
Klingt eigentlich ganz pfiffig.
Ist ein ganz altes Prinzip.
Also ist im Prinzip ein umgedrehter Kühlschrank.
Im Kühlschrank ist es ja kalt und die Rückseite warm.
Und wenn Sie jetzt den Kühlschrank sage ich mal offen ins Fenster machen, die Tür auf, nach draußen stellen und hinten die Heizrippen ins Fenster ist das im Prinzip eine Art Wärmepumpe.
Macht man natürlich dann etwas anders und effizienter, aber vom Prinzip ist es glaube ich jedem bekannt.
Macht das auch Sinn bei Gebäuden, die mit Gasetagenheizungen schon betrieben werden?
Oder sind das nur so Dinge, die man mit so einer zentralen Versorgung realisieren kann?
Man kann das sicherlich auch kleiner im dezentralen System machen.
Die Stückzahl, die wir mit Wärmepumpen derzeit verkaufen, sind halt ungleich kleiner als was wir mit Gas- und Ölheizung brauchen.
Da ist auch noch ein bisschen Entwicklungsbedarf, muss man ganz klar sagen.
Also es ist noch nicht so, dass man sagt, wir können das jetzt 1 zu 1 machen.
Also die Wärmepumpen, die heute da sind, sind schon ganz okay, aber wenn wir jetzt sagen, in 20 Jahren wollen wir alles 100% mit Wärmepumpen machen, dann müssen die halt auch noch ein paar Hausaufgaben erledigen, genau solche kleineren Einheiten die Effizienzen ein bisschen verbessern.
Man muss auch dann gucken, dass man möglichst zum Beispiel die Wärmepumpen dann betreibt, wenn die Sonne scheint.
Also das Anpassen an das Solarangebot noch verbessern.
Also da gibt es noch einige Hausaufgaben zu erledigen.
Technisch ist es durchaus möglich, das dann zu ersetzen, ja.
Okay, wenn man jetzt nochmal so eine Bestandsaufnahme des Ist macht, wir haben einige Segmente lokalisiert, wo man was tun könnte, einige wo auch was getan wird, wenige wo sich auch schon was entwickelt, aber wie hinterher sind wir denn eigentlich hinter dem, wie es sein müsste derzeit?
Das ist immer eine Frage der Perspektive, was muss sein?
Also ich denke, ein Hauptpunkt ist der Klimaschutz, den werden wir gleich mal beleuchten.
Und viele haben auch das Gefühl, dass wir viel weiter sind mit der Energiewende als wir eigentlich wirklich de facto sind.
Weil alle auf den Strom schauen.
Im Strombereich haben wir 35 % erneuerbare.
Wir hatten dann den zweiten Bereich, die Wärme, da sind es 13 % und wir hatten den Verkehr, da sind es 5 %.
Und deswegen sind wir im Bundesdurchschnitt bei gut 13 % erneuerbare oder andersrum ausgedrückt 87 % der Energiewende fehlen noch.
Um einfach mal die Aufgabe zu verdeutlichen.
Das heißt also wir haben zwar schon einiges gemacht, wir sind von 2 auf 13 %, das ist für ein Industrieland. Also da ist Deutschland unter Industrieländern sicherlich durchaus ein Vorbild.
Von fast gar nichts auf 1/6 fast nicht ganz.
Dass ist schon ganz okay, aber wie gesagt die 87 % die fehlen noch.
Und das müssen wir jetzt hier in den nächsten 20 Jahren möglichst dann durchziehen.
Das zeigt eigentlich die Dimensionen.
Das heißt wir müssen praktisch mehr als das sechsfache von dem machen, was wir die letzten 30 Jahre gemacht haben in den nächsten 20 Jahren, wenn wir die Energiewende durchziehen wollen.
Weil wir müssen den Klimaschutz im Auge haben.
Es gibt ja das Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen zum Glück.
Das sagt, dass wir uns Mühe geben sollten, die globale Erwärmung auf 1,5 °C zu begrenzen.
Um das mal einzuordnen, weil mit so Temperaturen können viele gar nichts anfangen.
Der Temperaturanstieg seit der letzten Eiszeit bis zur vorindustriellen Zeit hat etwa 3,5 Grad betragen.
Das heißt also 3,5 Grad letzte Eiszeit bis heute, wir haben jetzt 1° Temperaturerwärmung schon erreicht.
Das ist also sage ich mal wieder umgerechnet fast eine Drittel Eiszeit schon mal vom Temperaturdelta on the top obendrauf.
In 150 Jahren.
Ja wobei 150 Jahre, also de facto ist eigentlich eher die letzten 30 Jahre passiert.
30 bis 50 Jahre.
Klar also gerechnet wird immer über die letzten 150 Jahre, aber wir haben ja dieses exponentielle Wachstum, also eigentlich erst seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg sind die Emissionen so stark explodiert, dass wir da wirklich ein massives Problem damit haben.
Ein Grad haben wir erreicht.
Die Prognosen sagen, wenn wir Business as usual machen, werden wir gegen Ende des Jahrhunderts 4-5° plus haben und das wird mehr sein als der Temperaturunterschied von der Eiszeit bis heute.
Und das muss man einfach mal sehen, also dass man einfach noch mal überlegt.
Also zur Zeiten der Eiszeit war Berlin von meterdicken Gletschern bedeckt, wir hatten Meeresspiegel, die über 100 Meter tiefer lagen.
Die Erde war eine komplett andere.
Sagen wir mal andere Gemacht, die Menschheit hat ja auch die Eiszeit überlebt.
Nur damals hatten die Menschen die Chance weiterzuziehen.
Also wenn die Umgebungsbedingungen sich verändert haben dann und verschlechtert haben, also in Berlin hat damals niemand gewohnt, weil hier war Gletschergebiet.
Das heißt wir sind dann erst später, als die Bedingungen sich verändert haben, dann nach Berlin eingewandert in die Bereiche.
Und das heißt die Leute konnten sich den wandelnden Bedingungen einfach durch Weiterziehen anpassen.
Das geht heute nicht mehr, weil der Planet ist dicht besiedelt.
Wir sehen wie schlecht wir schon mit ein paar Flüchtlingen zurechtkommen.
Das ist ja wirklich eine vergleichsweise kleine Zahl.
Wenn wir einfach diese radikalen Veränderungen seit der Eiszeit nochmals übertragen, dass ähnliche Veränderungen in den nächsten 100 Jahren nochmal stattfinden, dann kann man sagen, werden wir wahrscheinlich ein Drittel der Weltbevölkerung auf die Reise schicken.
Und dann muss man sich einfach mal vorstellen, was auf unserem Planeten dann los ist.
Also das ist für mich die größte Herausforderung eigentlich dieses Jahrhunderts, dieses Problem abzuwenden.
Und da sagt die Klimaforschung, 1,5 Grad ist sozusagen das Höchste der Eisenbahn, wo wir dann auch den Stoppstrich ziehen müssen.
Das ist nicht ganz eine halbe Eiszeit schon on the top obendrauf.
Und das hat die Politik eigentlich abgenickt vor zwei Jahren auf dem Pariser Klimaschutzgipfel und Deutschland hat das auch einstimmig beschlossen.
Das heißt also wir haben jetzt einen Beschluss, dass wir alles tun werden, um 1,5 Grad zu erreichen.
Wir wissen aus der Klimaforschung, dass wir dazu eigentlich in den nächsten 20 Jahren CO2-neutral werden müssten.
Also 1,5 on top auf die ein Prozent, die wir jetzt schon haben?
Nein, 1 Grad haben wir jetzt schon, also ein halbes dürfen wir noch.
Okay.
Also um das mal einzuordnen.
Also da sieht man auch da, dass das Delta noch relativ klein ist.
Und wir wissen, dass wir dafür etwa 20 Jahre Zeit haben, also hier CO2-neutral zu werden.
Das heißt, wenn ich das wirklich ernst meine aus Sicht der Politik und auch die Bekenntnisse zum Klimaschutz, müsste man jetzt eine Strategie entwickeln, wie wir unsere Energieversorgung im Bereich Strom, Wärme und Verkehr in den nächsten 20 Jahren komplett umgekrempelt.
Von den heutigen fossilen Energieträgern zu komplett CO2-freien Energieträgern.
Das ist eigentlich die Herausforderung der Energiewende.
Dass wir, ich werde immer gefragt, kann man sich vorstellen, 100 % erneuerbare Energien zu haben?
Also in 500 Jahren werden wir das mit Sicherheit haben, weil dann ist Öl, Kohle und Gas, selbst wenn wir keinen Klimaschutz machen, alle.
Dann werden die Menschen ja sowieso irgendwas machen.
Das heißt es wird kommen.
Nur die Frage ist, wie schnell schaffen wir es, schaffen wir 100 % erneuerbare Energien so schnell umzusetzen, dass wir das Klima noch retten können?
Oder machen wir das in einem Tempo, was zu langsam ist für den Klimaschutz und machen es dann sowieso.
Dann wär's natürlich doch auch sinnvoll, wenn wir wissen, es kommt doch sowieso.
Dass wir es dann einfach versuchen bisschen zu beschleunigen und vorzuziehen.
Es ist ein Weg, der kommen wird und das haben die Chinesen auch erkannt.
Die machen ja jetzt den massiven Einstieg in die erneuerbaren, in die Elektromobilität nicht unbedingt nur, um das Klima zu retten, sondern auch aus wirtschaftlichen Gesichtspunkten.
Also China hat im letzten Jahr auch, also wir haben über die Elektromobilität schon geredet im Photovoltaik- im Solarenergiebereich genauso stark zugelegt.
Also China hat über 20 mal so viel Photovoltaikanlagen letztes Jahr im eigenen Land aufgebaut, wie wir in Deutschland.
Die gehen massiv in den Bereich, ja weil sie auch ein bisschen die Luft sauber machen müssen, aber weil das auch die Schlüsseltechnologie für die nächsten Jahre ist, wo man viel Geld verdienen muss.
Und das wird in Deutschland eigentlich nicht gesehen, man hält an den alten Technologien fest und man hat überhaupt kein Konzept, wie man die Energiewende mit dem Klimaschutz hinkriegen muss.
Es gab jetzt jüngst eine Studie, die auch gesagt hat, wenn Deutschland so weitermacht wie bisher mit dem Tempo der Energiewende und die ganze Welt dem Beispiel folgen würde, dann bedeutet das einen Temperaturanstieg von etwa 4 Grad, also nochmal eine Eiszeit on the top oben drauf, das ist das was wir derzeit in Deutschland haben.
Klingt ja nicht so schön.
Das klingt aus Sicht der Wissenschaft, ganz klar wir sehen das, wir beobachten das, wir machen auch Empfehlungen.
Die Politik ist aber in Deutschland offensichtlich momentan nicht in der Lage, warum auch immer, entsprechende Maßnahmen und Sachen einzuleiten.
Und die Konsequenzen werden halt einfach massive Klimaproblematik sein.
Ich hoffe mal, dass wir es schaffen, auch durch Diskussionen, jetzt in den nächsten Jahren auch noch das Tempo entsprechend zu beschleunigen und die Maßnahmen einzuleiten.
Ansonsten gibt es zwei Sachen, die man sehen kann.
Erst mal die Chinesen werden die Technik vorantreiben, so dass die dann einfach günstig als Import dann nach Deutschland kommt.
Heute schon ist Solarstrom nicht mehr teurer als Kohlestrom in Deutschland.
Wenn Sie neue Anlagen bauen.
Wenn die Chinesen so weiter machen, wird in absehbarer Zeit auch Solarstrom billiger sein als Kohlestrom.
Das heißt allein aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen wird die Technologie kommen.
Die Frage ist halt nur, machen wir die dann oder machen das dann die Chinesen?
Und die andere Frage ist natürlich dann auch einfach mit dem Klimaschutz.
Also wir werden ähnliche Ereignisse sehen wie durch Tschernobyl oder durch Fukushima.
Also was wir im Kernenergiebereich gesehen haben durch den Klimawandel.
Wenn man die Augen offen hält sieht man, die Amerikaner sind zum Beispiel auch sehr stark gebeutelt worden, dieses Jahr Hurricanesaison mit über 200 Milliarden Euro an Schäden.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Also innerhalb von wenigen Tagen sind dort ja ganze Städte verwüstet worden.
200 Milliarden Defekt.
Und da kann man sich einfach überlegen, wir reden über die Kosten der Energiewende und dass uns 20 Milliarden pro Jahr zu viel sind.
Deutschland war bislang noch verschont von solchen Sachen, aber ist auch nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis einfach diese Veränderungen auch Deutschland treffen.
Sei es einfach durch lokale Klimaereignisse oder durch Flüchtlingszahlen, die einfach durch den Klimawandel ausgelöst werden.
Einer dieser Hurricanes, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, hat ja tatsächlich sogar die irische Küste erreicht in diesem Jahr.
Genau, ja gut, das sind dann Ausläufer im Endeffekt noch gewesen.
Aber wir haben ja auch in Deutschland die Extremwetterereignisse gesehen.
Also Zunahme der Stürme.
Die Bilder auch, die wir hier in Berlin jetzt gesehen haben, waren ja auch beeindruckend, wo die U-Bahn-Schächte vollgelaufen sind.
Also wenn man die Augen offen hält und auch wenn man mit der älteren Generation redet.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagt, okay das ist jetzt ein einmaliges Ereignis.
Also wenn man wirklich mit Großeltern mal redet und sagt, wie war denn das zu eurer Kindheit, wann hat da der Winter angefangen, wie hart war der?
Dann wird man auch hören, das war damals schon anders.
Also dieses 1 Grad plus, was wir haben, zeigt sich schon ganz deutlich, man muss halt hinschauen.
Und da gucken halt viele ganz gerne weg.
Das Problem ist aber, durch das Weggucken wird das Problem nicht kleiner, es wird sich ja potenzieren.
Und spätestens irgendwann, wenn das so groß ist, dass einfach die Schäden größer sind als das, was die Volkswirtschaft leisten kann, dann wird man irgendwie handeln müssen, nur dann wird es wahrscheinlich zu spät sein.
Was müsste man jetzt eigentlich tun?
Also was wären jetzt sozusagen die unbedingt erforderlichen Maßnahmen, wo es derzeit einfach noch überhaupt nicht läuft?
Und was sind vor allem so die Bereiche, wo verfügbare Lösungen einfach gar nicht gesehen, obwohl sie im Prinzip da wären?
Ach wir kennen aus der Wissenschaft die Lösungen.
Es läuft momentan nirgendwo in Deutschland.
Wir hatten mal eine Energiewende, also auch angefangen, mittlerweile wurde die komplett eingestampft, kann man schon fast sagen.
Also wir wissen, dass die Hauptenergieträger künftig Solarenergie, also Photovoltaik und Windkraft sein werden, weil wir da einfach die größten Potenziale haben.
Wir gehen davon aus, dass wir aber, um in 20 Jahren 100% erneuerbare zu kriegen, werden wir den Windenergieausbau verdoppeln müssen, den Solarenergieausbau verzehnfachen.
WAs hat die Regierung gemacht?
Wir haben mit der letzten Regierung den Solarenergieausbau auf ein Viertel runtergefahren.
Der Windenergiezubau soll jetzt in zwei Jahren gestoppt werden.
Wir erwarten, wenn die Regeln sich nicht ändern, für 2019 den Ausbaustopp in der Windenergie.
Und da brauchen wir natürlich, also wie soll dann Klimaschutz funktionieren, wenn ich keine Technologien aufbaue, die entsprechend CO2-neutral etwas einsparen.
Dann gehe ich aus der Kernenergie noch raus, was ja sinnvoll ist aus den Risikosachen.
Nur wenn ich dann ein Ausbaustopp in der Windenergie habe, da werden die CO2-Emissionnen ja dann, irgendjemand muss den Strom ja ersetzen.
Wenn der dann aus Kohlestrom oder aus Gaskraftwerken kommt, entsteht zusätzliches CO2.
Das heißt ich sehe hier keinen Klimaschutzaspekt, der dann entsprechend da ist.
Das heißt wir müssten erst mal die Installationen für Solar- und Windenergie deutlich erhöhen, dass wir überhaupt erst mal die Mengen an CO2-neutralem Strom kriegen, die wir brauchen.
Das ist also Punkt Nummer 1.
Dann wissen wir ganz klar, wenn wir Solar- und Windenergie haben, die sind halt nicht immer da.
Ja dann bricht die Stromversorgung zusammen und Dunkelflaute.
Natürlich, wenn sie nicht da sind, brauchen wir Speicher.
Das heißt wir fokussieren uns derzeit auf eine Leitungsproblematik und eine Leitungsdiskussion.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen ein Scheingefecht.
Weil was hilft uns die beste Leitung, wenn wir wissen, dass wir irgendwann 100% erneuerbare haben, die im wesentlichen durch Solar- und Windenergie gedeckt werden, wenn wir dann wirklich im Winter mal nachts wenig Wind haben.
Dann hilft uns die Leitung halt nichts, sondern da brauchen wir einen Speicher.
Das heißt wir müssen jetzt massiv in den Ausbau der Speichertechnologien einsteigen.
Auch da kennen wir die Speicher, für den Kurzzeitspeicherbereich wird es die Batterie sein.
Für den Langzeitspeicherbereich reden wir von Power-to-Gas.
Das heißt da werden wir dann Überschussstrom aus Solar- und Windkraft in Wasserstoff und Methan umwandeln.
Das können wir relativ gut speichern, weil diese Speicher dazu, das sind Untertagespeicher, in Deutschland existieren schon, die kann man einfach mitnutzen.
Das sind so große Hohlräume unter den Städten.
Genau das sind ehemalige Lagerstätten von Öl und Gas, die man ausgebeutet hat oder auch Hohlräume, die man künstlich geschaffen hat, wo man dann einfach entsprechend hier wieder das künstlich erzeugte Methan dann einlagern kann.
Und mit den bestehenden Gasspeichern, die wir haben, kann man rein rechnerisch, wenn man da jetzt einfach Strom aus dem kompletten Gas, was gespeichert ist, Strom draus machen, könnten wir da mehrere Monate am Stück die deutsche Stromversorgung sicherstellen.
Das heißt also Gasspeicher …
Mehrere Monate?
Mehrere Monate ja.
Das heißt also die Gasspeicher sind da, was noch fehlt ist praktisch die Umwandlung von Strom aus Solar- und Windenergie in Gas.
Die fehlt im Sinne von, sie ist noch nicht entwickelt worden oder?
Doch, wir haben Prototypenanlagen, man muss sie aufbauen.
Ja.
Man muss sie einfach erst mal hinstellen.
Man muss natürlich gucken, momentan haben wir Prototypen.
Das heißt wir müssen jetzt schauen, dass wir über die Serienfertigung die Kosten noch senken von den Anlagen.
Die sind natürlich, weil sie haben ein paar Dutzend Anlagen gebaut jetzt deutschlandweit, wir brauchen einige tausende, insofern müssen wir da gucken, dass die Kosten da noch runtergehen, aber das kriegt man über die Serienfertigung hin und dann muss man das einfach aufbauen.
Und was wir da natürlich noch brauchen ist, dass wenn wir dann halt wirklich den Strom wieder brauchen, dann müssen wir aus dem gespeicherten Gas wieder Strom erzeugen und dafür brauchen wir dann entsprechend auch die entsprechenden Anlagen.
Also müssten wir jetzt Gaskraftwerke massiv aufbauen.
Und da wäre der Schritt ganz klar, raus aus der Kohle, Einstieg in Gas, übergangsweise können wir das mit Erdgas machen.
Und das Erdgas können wir dann schrittweise ersetzen durch erneuerbares Gas.
Und so viele Gaskraftwerke gibt es noch nicht in Deutschland?
Nö, also nicht die Mengen, die wir brauchen.
Es gibt ein paar, aber es gibt...
Genau es gibt so eine Hand voll, das ist okay, aber von der Dimension her müssten wir das also nochmal um Größenordnungen steigern, was wir da haben.
Der Verkehr müsste auf jeden Fall nachhaltig angefasst werden...
Genau der Verkehr, ganz klar...
ist logisch.
Selbstredend. Wenn ich jetzt also Benzin und Diesel habe, da entsteht CO2.
Nicht nur das, also wir haben ja auch die Stickoxide.
Ganz andere Problematik, 7000 Tote durch Luftverschmutzung im Verkehr alleine in Deutschland.
Also das ist ja so ein Thema.
Und dann was war jetzt neulich in der Diskussion?
Also VW, ich finde ja toll, dass die Konzerne sich jetzt bewegen und auch der Herr Müller von VW sagt, er will aus dem Diesel raus und dann in die Elektromobilität.
Und dann kommen Vertreter von der FDP und sagen dann, der Diesel-Judas.
Also jetzt müssen wir einfach mal gucken.
Aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht werden 7000 Menschen sterben im Jahr durch die Abgase im Verkehr.
Und was würde denn passieren, wenn in Deutschland 7000 Menschen auf offener Straße erschossen würden?
Gucken, was da die konservativen Parteien machen würden.
Und so wird einfach nur mit den Achseln gezuckt und gesagt, ja das ist Deutsche Technologie, die können wir nicht aufgeben.
Also das halte ich auch schon, also menschlich für relativ fragwürdig
Wir sichern ja Arbeitsplätze, sagt man dann.
Ja. Gut kann man überlegen, wie viele Tote pro Arbeitsplatz sind, das ist dann auch schon eine relativ traurige Zahlen.
Habe ich jetzt mal ausgerechnet, aber das wollen die Leute dann natürlich nicht hören.
Aber natürlich ganz klar, CO2-Problematik ist natürlich das andere.
IM Verkehr muss man raus und die einzige Möglichkeit, die wir da haben ist, was wir vorhin schon besprochen haben, die Elektromobilität.
Das heißt wir müssen den kompletten Verkehr in den nächsten 20 Jahren auf Elektromobilität umstellen.
Und dann kann man wieder rückwärts rechnen.
Wenn wir sagen, wir müssen in 20 Jahren fertig sein.
Ein Auto lebt 15 Jahre, dann darf eigentlich der letzte Verbrenner 2025 vom Band laufen.
Das wäre eigentlich die Konsequenz, wenn ich den Klimaschutz ernst meine.
Das haben ja nicht mal die Grünen hingekriegt.
Herr Kretschmann meinte ja, 2030 ist ja nicht machbar, weil wir in Deutschland die nicht betanken können.
Das stimmt ja momentan, aber da muss man einfach wie die Chinesen ein paar Ladestationen aufbauen.
Die kriegen das innerhalb von drei Jahren hin, 4 Millionen Ladestationen hinzukriegen, warum kriegen wir in Deutschland nicht ein paar Steckdosen hingebaut.
Also da fühle ich mich auch als Elektroingenieur nicht wirklich ernst genommen.
Daran kann doch die Energiewende nicht scheitern.
Netze und Stromverteilung und Strombedarf ist auch immer wieder so ein Argument in der Debatte von, es gibt ja gar nicht genug Strom, oder, das braucht ja alles viel zu viel und soviel Strom kann man ja dann gar nicht erzeugen, wie man ja bräuchte, um all diese ganzen Elektrofahrzeuge zu füllen.
Manches davon sind sicherlich auch Nebelkerzen. Ist etwas schwierig das auseinanderzuhalten.
Wie realistisch ist denn ein solcher Netzausbau und überhaupt der Umbau auf komplett Strom?
Wenn wir jetzt sozusagen die Wohnungen mit Strom heizen, die Autos mit Strom betanken, wenn sozusagen alles, was bisher noch aus anderen Energiequellen kam, auf einmal mit Strom ist, ist das ein Problem in irgendeiner Form, diese technische Infrastruktur dafür bereit zu stellen und den Strom auch wirklich effizient durchzuleiten?
Wo muss der Strom künftig erzeugt werden, damit das zu leisten ist?
Also Problem ist es nicht, man muss es einfach machen.
Aber der Strombedarf wird natürlich ansteigen, und zwar signifikant, das ist klar.
Wir haben letztes Jahr eine Studie dazu ja rausgebracht.
Wir gehen davon aus, dass wenn wir sehr effizient den Strom für den Verkehr und für die Heizungen einsetzen und man darf den Industriebereich, die Industrieprozesse müssen wir ja auch dekarbonisieren, die müssen wir auch noch mit auf dem Schirm haben, dann gehen wir davon aus, dass sich der Strombedarf in Deutschland mindestens mal verdoppelt.
Also das ist die Situation.
Also er wird nicht ins Unendliche gehen.
Der Verkehr ist gar nicht das schlimmste dabei.
Also Verkehr macht ungefähr bloß 20% aus, aber da kommt halt die Wärme noch mit dazu und die Industrie.
Und dann kommt man auf etwa eine Verdopplung des Strombereichs.
Und das müssen wir natürlich auch bei den Erzeugungskapazitäten mit auf dem Schirm haben.
Das heißt wenn wir die Solar- und Windenergie weiter so ausbauen, wie die Regierung das plant, dann kommen wir auf vielleicht 20-25% erneuerbaren Anteil 2040.
Bezogen auf den Gesamtenergie- und Gesamtstromeinsatz, den wir dann bräuchten.
Also das ist halt viel zu wenig.
Das heißt da muss man hingehen.
Dann ist natürlich ganz klar die Frage, wie wird der Strom verteilt.
Und wie sieht das mit den Leitungen aus?
Also de facto wissen wir heute noch gar nicht, welche Leitungen wir brauchen.
Weil das hängt ja sehr stark davon ab, wo ich die Anlagen aufbaue.
Also wir haben jetzt momentan in Bayern quasi einen Ausbaustopp für Windenergie.
Also Sie dürfen nach der Gesetzeslage kam mehr Windenergie zubauen.
De facto würde man dann diesen Strom natürlich in Norddeutschland erzeugen.
Wenn ich Bayern keinen Windstrom habe, den in Norddeutschland mache, brauche ich natürlich eine Leitung, die den Strom von Norddeutschland nach Bayern transportiert.
Ich kann mir aber auch … ja dann regen sich aber natürlich die Leute in Bayern auf, dass sie Strommasten kriegen.
Also einen Tod muss ich sterben, entweder die Windenergie vor Ort oder halt eine Stromleitung.
Also gut die Stromleitung kann ich noch verbuddeln, das kann ich mit der Windkraftanlage nicht machen.
Aber das wird auch unendlich teuer, dann regen sich wieder alle drüber auf, dass der Strom zu teuer ist.
Also man muss dann schon ein bisschen Farbe bekennen.
Also meine Intension wäre es eher, den Strom dezentral zu erzeugen, also auch in Süddeutschland.
Windenergie, Photovoltaik, dann kann man den Leitungsausbau deutlich reduzieren.
Und dann kann man auch sich überlegen, zum Beispiel Überschussstrom in Norddeutschland, wenn ich Überschüsse habe, auch in Gas gleich umzuwandeln und den ins Gasnetz einspeichern und über eine Pipeline zum Beispiel nach Süddeutschland liefern.
Wenn Süddeutschland zum Beispiel in der Lage ist, sich dann auch über längere Zeiträume selber zu versorgen.
Also das ist noch nicht ganz klar.
Eine Leitung schadet nicht für die Energiewende, kostet erst mal nur viel Geld.
Also wenn ich jetzt Leitungen baue, die ich vielleicht in den Maßen nicht brauche, habe ich halt Geld vernichtet, aber ich habe jetzt nicht sonst irgendwelche falschen Weichenstellungen gemacht.
Insofern kann man Leitungen durchaus bauen.
Nur es gibt ein Netzentwicklungsplan, das heißt darauf sind die aktuellen Leitungsplanungen, die heute gemacht werden, ausgelegt.
Und dieser Netzentwicklungsplan sieht noch den Weiterbetrieb von den Kohlekraftwerken weitgehend ungemindert bis zum Jahre 2030 vor.
Und das heißt man müsste jetzt auch mal durchrechnen, was passiert denn, wenn wir im Jahr 2030 einen Kohleausstieg machen, was wir eigentlich für den Klimaschutz tunlichst machen sollten.
Und dann haben wir eventuell komplett andere Leitungswege oder ganz andere Prioritäten für den Leitungszubau als man heute hat.
Weil dann fallen ja auch Kohlekraftwerke im Ruhrgebiet, Hamburg, Moorburg zum Beispiel weg und man kann ja auch den Strom aus Norddeutschland erst mal dort dann versenken.
Wo heute noch die Kohlekraftwerke die Wege blockieren und dann kann man nochmal neu drüber nachdenken.
Deswegen ich finde diese Leitungsdiskussion auch ein Stück weit unehrlich.
Wir haben einen Netzentwicklungsplan, der keine schnelle Energiewende vorsieht.
Wir haben Leitungen, die angeblich unabdingbar sind.
Der Südlink selber, die Übertragungskapazität ist ein Jahr Zubau Windenergie, die man da durchleiten kann.
Auch das zeigt eigentlich, also die Leitung schadet nicht, aber für die Energiewende wäre es eigentlich sinnvoller, wenn es schnell gehen soll, den Strom dezentral aufzubauen.
Lieber nochmal das Paket aufschnüren, warum nicht in Bayern auch Windräder hinstellen und dann entsprechend auch lokale Speicher und dann kommt man mit viel viel weniger Leitung auch hin.
Aber das ist wie gesagt noch offen, das muss die Gesellschaft entscheiden, ob wir nun Windräder in Bayern haben wollen oder Stromleitungen.
Was wäre denn mit Solardächern in Bayern?
Das ist doch sicherlich vermittelbarer, oder?
Genau, Solardächer sind immer ganz gut.
Problem ist halt, dass wir im Winter halt keinen Solarstrom oder wenig haben.
Also das heißt wir brauchen dann auch mehr Strom im Winter.
Das heißt also da ohne Windenergie wird es nicht gehen.
Solar ist ganz gut.
Wir gehen davon aus bei unseren Berechnungen, dass künftig etwa die Windenergie so knapp 2/3 machen wird.
Die Photovoltaik knapp ein Drittel für die Stromerzeugung.
Für dieses Drittel Stromerzeugung brauchen wir ungefähr 0,6% der Landesfläche, die wir mit Photovoltaik belegen müssen.
Weil immer gefragt wird, wo sollen die alle stehen?
Die Hälfte davon werden wir im Gebäudebereich unterkriegen, die andere Hälfte müssen wir irgendwo auf die grüne Wiese stellen dann.
Moment, die Rechnung habe ich nicht ganz nachvollziehen können.
0,6%…?
… der Landesfläche müssen wir mit Solarenergie belegen, um ein Drittel Solarstrom inklusive Verkehr, Wärme und so weiter dann zu machen.
Also ein Drittel des Gesamtbedarfs?
Des Gesamtbedarfs, genau.
Etwa 0,6% der Landesfläche, da kommt eine gewisse Quadratmeterfläche rum, die Hälfte dieser Solarfläche würden wir dann im Gebäudebereich unterkriegen auf den Dächern.
Also 0,3%.
Das heißt da geht schon was?
Ich weiß nicht, 0,6% klingt jetzt erst mal wenig, aber auf ein komplettes Land ist das ja dann schon irgendwie so eine Kleinstadt oder?
Genau es ist schon eine größere Fläche, man wird die Anlagen sehen.
Genauso bei der Windenergie, also man sieht sie ja heute schon.
Also die Windenergiemenge müssten wir verdrei- oder vervierfachen nochmal.
Das heißt nicht unbedingt, dass wir 3-4 mal so viele Anlagen haben.
Die moderneren Anlagen sind ja auch größer und leistungsfähiger.
Also wir brauchen 3-4 mal so viel Leistung.
Wenn Sie jetzt eine kleine Anlage durch eine neue ersetzen, da kommt da auch manchmal 4-5 mal so viel Leistung raus.
Also deswegen gibt es da gewisse Synergieeffekte, die man da noch nutzen kann.
Aber auch da wird man die Windenergie noch weiter sehen.
Und wir müssen auch wie gesagt die Frage mit Süddeutschland nochmal aufschnüren, ob es sinnvoll ist, dann wirklich da keine Windkraftanlagen aufzubauen.
Weil die modernen Windräder sind in großen Höhen auch in Süddeutschland relativ leistungsfähig.
Ja und bei der Photovoltaik wie gesagt …
Also es ist eigentlich gerade ein bisschen absurd, dass ausgerechnet in Bayern, da wo es auch gute Standorte gäbe für Windenergie, genau das nicht erfolgen soll.
Genau man hat das ja über die Abstandsregelung gemacht.
Also man hat eine enorme Abstandsregelung beschlossen, dass man also 2 Kilometer Abstand mindestens mal braucht für die Windräder.
Wenn die größer werden, noch mehr zu Gebäuden.
Und dann finden Sie halt überall eine Scheune, die irgendwo in Bayern rumsteht, was dann einfach den Mindestabstand wieder zerstört, so dass Sie kaum mehr Standorte übrig haben.
In anderen Bundesländern ist es die Hälfte von dem Abstand oder noch weniger.
Und das zerstört halt einfach die Standorte, die wir in Bayern haben, und das muss man halt einfach nochmal aufschnüren.
Also Bayern hat ja auch das größte Problem mit dem Kernenergieausstieg.
Das heißt also wenn da die Kernkraftwerke abschalten, wird Bayern irgendwann die Frage beantworten müssen, wo kommt der Strom her?
Und möglicherweise diskutieren wir dann nochmal, ob man die Kernkraftwerke 1-2 Jahre länger laufen lassen muss, weil man einfach versäumt hat, die Alternativen rechtzeitig aufzubauen.
Und das wäre natürlich auch schade.
Ein dezentrales Netz.
Derzeit haben wir ja eher so eine Grundidee in unserem Stromnetz, wo man sagt, es gibt große Versorger, große Kraftwerke, Atomkraftwerke, Kohlekraftwerke etc., alles was es halt gibt, und die schieben dann halt so an die Verbraucher den Strom.
Wenn man jetzt das Ganze mehr so aus der Idee heraus, kleine Windanlagen, kleine Solaranlagen, Dächer, Autos und so weiter, also alles was irgendwo Fläche hat, wo man wunderbar Photovoltaik zum Beispiel betreiben könnte oder eben auch Windenergie, dann muss es ja quasi überall neue Einspeisepunkte geben und das Ganze muss ja ins ich auch in irgendeiner Form geregelt werden.
Je nachdem wo gerade ein Stromangebot ist und wo vor allem auch eine Nachfrage ist.
Genau.
Existiert das schon?
Ist das irgendwie knifflig aufzubauen?
Was muss da noch entwickelt werden?
Ist unser Netz überhaupt so weit, um so was zu realisieren?
Im Prinzip  ja.
Das Problem ist auch wieder das alte Denken insgesamt.
Also momentan ist es so, wenn es Probleme im Netz gibt, dann fahren wir halt die Solar- und Windkraftanlagen runter und die klassischen Kraftwerke regeln das dann aus.
Das ist die Denkweise, die wir momentan haben.
Problem ist natürlich, wenn es irgendwann keine klassischen Kraftwerke mehr gibt, wer regelt das dann aus?
Das heißt man müsste tunlichst jetzt dafür sorgen, dass also auch Solar- und Windräder in Gemeinschaft mit Batterien das dann ausregeln.
Das geht ja, also Sie können mit Batteriespeichern genauso die Versorgungssicherheit gewährleisten wie mit dem fetten Atom- oder Kohlekraftwerk.
Man muss es halt nur angehen.
Momentan wird das sozusagen alles als ad on für die Stromversorgung gesehen.
Das sind also so ganz ergänzende Technologien, aber die großen Kraftwerke sind immer noch für das Wesen verantwortlich.
Es ist auch das Interesse der entsprechenden Betreiber gar nicht da, groß was zu ändern, weil ist ja auch so ein bisschen eine Überlebensversicherung.
Wenn ich immer für die Versorgungssicherheit noch als Backup erforderlich bin, dann kann man mich ja nicht abschaffen.
Und da müssten wir natürlich tunlichst dran arbeiten und das wäre ja auch so ein bisschen Exportschlager.
Dass Deutschland also auch mal eine Versorgung aufbaut, die auch wirklich zu 100% erneuerbar funktionieren kann.
Das geht momentan technisch gar nicht.
Das heißt also selbst wenn wir rein rechnerisch Strom für 100% hätten aus Solar- und Windenergie.
Da waren wir ja schon, also 70-80 hatten wir schon mal.
Wenn wir jetzt ausbauen und eben 100 wären, wäre aber die Konsequenz, dass wir 20% Windstrom abschalten, weil wir noch die klassischen Kraftwerke für das Sicherstellen der Netzleistung brauchen.
Weil man versäumt hat, die Bedingungen so zu ändern, dass das Windkraft, Solar und die Speicher dann in Kombination auch abdecken können.
Also das muss man tunlichst angehen.
Weil wenn wir sehr schnell Solar- und Windenergie ausbauen, werden wir auch sehr häufiger Zeiten kriegen, wo wir 100% haben.
Was momentan technisch aufgrund der Randbedingungen gar nicht möglich ist.
Also technisch wäre es schon möglich, aber es ist gar nicht zulässig, weil die Versorgungssicherheit nach den jetzigen Randbedingungen nicht gewährleistet werden kann.
Also ein großes Problem, was man auf alle Fälle angehen muss.
Ansonsten mit den Leitungen, die Anlagen sind wesentlich dezentraler.
Ganz klar, wenn Sie jetzt eine Photovoltaikanlage auf dem Hausdach haben, den Strom im wesentlichen im Haus verbrauchen.
Wenn die Elektromobilität dazukommt, dann kann man ja auch noch überlegen, dass wir gesteuert laden.
Also das heißt das Elektroauto dann aufladen, wenn die Sonne scheint.
Dann reduzieren wir ja auch die Transportkapazitäten.
Und das ist natürlich ein großer Vorteil.
Trotzdem haben wir natürlich andere Übertragungswege.
Das heißt das fette Kohlekraftwerk vor der Stadt wird ja dann nicht mehr gebraucht.
Der Weg von dort, die Leitungen, vielleicht baut man da mal eine Speicher- oder Erzeugungsanlage.
Man kann sie vielleicht noch mit nutzen, aber dann sind die großen Verbraucher vielleicht irgendwann die Schnellladestationen an den Autobahntankstellen.
Das heißt die Leitungen muss man dann verstärken.
Also es wird nicht ohne Leitungszubau gehen, weil sich einfach auch die Verbrauchs- und Erzeugungsschwerpunkte verändern.
Und da wäre es auch sinnvoll, heute schon drüber nachzudenken.
Also gerade wenn man die Elektromobilität dann durchdenkt und sagt, wir haben den Urlaubsverkehr und alle wollen dann nach Süddeutschland fahren, dann braucht man natürlich auch sehr große Ladezentren.
Und die brauchen natürlich dann in der Spitze auch richtig fett Strom.
Das wäre ja heute auch technisch von den Leitungswegen noch gar nicht möglich.
Das heißt wenn ich jetzt vorausschauend agiere, dann muss man sagen, okay wir bauen jetzt auch entlang den Autobahnen diese Schnellladezentren auf.
Am Anfang klein, aber mit dem Potenzial das zu erweitern mit den Leitungsanschlüssen, dass wir auch mal 500 Autos gleichzeitig laden können.
Und das muss man natürlich jetzt schon vorsehen.
Wie gesagt, wenn ich nach China gucke, werde ich immer so ein bisschen neidisch.
Wenn die da 4 Millionen Ladepunkte machen, dann passiert das genau, das was man in Deutschland eigentlich machen müsste.
Und bei uns findet ja nicht mal das Denken darüber statt.
Woran hakt es denn?
Was ist denn kaputt?
Also ich meine man hat so viele Fakten auf dem Tisch, es ist schon so lange darüber diskutiert worden.
Sind wir hier wirklich jetzt nur unter dem Druck einer Besitzstandswahrerlobby im industriellen Bereich?
Oder fehlt es einfach an irgendwas, ist hier irgendein magischer Trunk nicht getrunken worden?
Was ist denn kaputt, wie nehmen Sie das denn wahr?
Ich meine, Sie werden doch auch Kontakt mit der Politik haben?
Na gut, die Politik sagt aber, wir können das nicht durchsetzen.
Also durch alle Parteien hin, bis hin zu den Grünen.
Also auch die Grünen Ausbauziele sind ja für den Klimaschutz besser als das was die anderen machen, aber aus unserer Sicht immer noch nicht ausreichend, wenn man wirklich das Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen ansieht.
Gegen wen kann man es nicht durchsetzen?
Gegenüber den Lobbyinteressen und gegenüber der Bevölkerung, die offensichtlich noch nicht aufgeklärt genug ist.
Muss man ganz klar sagen.
Ich glaube den meisten, wenn man jetzt draußen mal umfragt, wie schnell müssen wir die Energiewende durchziehen, dass wir da noch 20 Jahre Zeit haben für den Klimaschutz, ist glaube ich den meisten gar nicht bewusst.
Einfach diese Dringlichkeit und diese Dynamik, die wir brauchen.
Und viele haben ja das Gefühl, es funktioniert.
Und wenn Sie fragen, was bedeutet Energiewende, dann sagen viele erstmal, Kernenergieausstieg.
Und der ist ja 2023 abgeschlossen.
Damit ist für viele erst mal die Energiewende erledigt.
Das heißt wir haben erst mal ein Kommunikationsproblem.
Das heißt also diese Dramatik des Klimawandels ist einfach noch nicht angekommen.
Und das sehe ich auch bei meinen Vorträgen.
Immer wenn ich erst mal wirklich diese Zusammenhänge, auch das Beispiel mit der Eiszeit erläutere, dann sehe ich erst mal ganz betroffene Gesichter.
Weil viele Leute das zum ersten Mal hören, wie schlimm es eigentlich um den Klimaschutz steht.
Da haben wir andere Parteien, die ja sagen, CO2 ist gut für den Pflanzenwachstum.
Also so was gibt es ja auf der anderen Seite auch.
Wo einfach ja die Wissenschaft also … ich fühle mich da nicht ernst genommen.
Und wir hatten ja neulich eine Podiumsdiskussion bei Frau Maischberger, wo dann gefragt wird, glauben Sie an den Klimawandel?
Und da sind sich die Journalisten nicht zu schade.
Genauso könnte ich gut sagen, das ist Physik, glauben Sie an die Schwerkraft?
Würde ja auch keiner mehr heute fragen.
Aber auf dem Niveau bewegen wir uns einfach noch.
Das erklärt natürlich, ja gut, solange ich nicht weiß, ob es die Schwerkraft gibt oder nicht, muss ich auch kein Geländer bauen.
Also auf dem Niveau bewegen wir uns und das ist natürlich erst mal schwierig.
Und da gibt es natürlich auch sehr viele Lobbygruppen, die da Interesse daran haben.
Wir sehen das in Amerika.
Also die Freunde von Donald Trump, das sind auch die, die nach Öl bohren und Kohle fördern und Verbrennungsmotoren bauen.
Die haben natürlich erst mal kein Interesse auch an einer schnellen Energiewende und an Klimaschutz.
Die werden das nicht vermeiden können, aber sie werden es natürlich versuchen herauszuzögern.
Und natürlich kann ich das herauszögern.
Ich kann strenge Umweltstandards für Kohlekraftwerke beschließen, dann ist das Zeitalter der Kohle schneller beendet.
Oder ich kann sehr lasche Umweltstandards bewegen und auch keine Auflagen für den Klimaschutz machen, dann dauert das ein bisschen länger.
Und das sehen wir halt jetzt auch vor allen Dingen in den Industrieländern.
Die Entwicklungsländer sind da weiter, weil die diese Verdrängung nicht haben.
Also wir verdrängen ja, wir haben ja nicht so eine Wachstumspolitik mehr.
Wir verdrängen ja im wesentlichen alte Kraftwerke, alte Motorentechnik durch neue.
Und dann gibt es halt auch immer Verlierer und die stehen natürlich mit beiden Beinen auf der Bremse.
Was wollen Sie denn machen als Verband der deutschen Schmierstoffindustrie, wenn Sie wissen, dass der Ölwechsel wegfällt.
Im Prinzip können Sie nur gegen die Elektromobilität arbeiten, weil für Sie gibt es kein Geschäftsmodell mehr in der Zukunft.
Und das sind natürlich dann diese Bremseffekte.
Und dann fängt es natürlich auch bei den Leuten selber an.
Also der Flug nach Mallorca oder das schöne T-Bone-Steak aus Argentinien, also für den Klimaschutz ist das auch nicht mehr okay.
Und dann muss man sich auch selber überlegen, also eigentlich müsste man selber den Lebensstil ein bisschen hinterfragen, die eine oder andere Antwort ist natürlich auch unbequem.
Und deswegen wird der Klimaschutz eigentlich auch so ganz gerne mal weggeschoben.
Sagen, für mich ist es unbequem, für die Politik ist es unbequem.
Man muss ja auch Maßnahmen durchsetzen.
Es gibt ja auch viele Deutsche, die ja gar nicht bereit sind, den Weg zu gehen.
Wenn ich jetzt Fliegen teurer mache, dann sind die Leute erst mal sauer, weil das Ticket nach Malle teurer wird und erkennen den Klimaschutzwert gar nicht.
Und das ist natürlich auch politisch ein heißes Eisen und da haben wir in Deutschland leider keine Politiker, die momentan sich trauen, das wirklich anzugehen.
Also es mangelt an Mut?
Ja ich denke wirklich an Mut.
Das heißt also in der Wissenschaft mit allen Kollegen, da gibt es auch schon Appelle und Brandbriefe und sonst irgendwie, dass wir den Klimaschutz machen wollen.
Aus der Wissenschaft ist das Problem erkannt, wir haben auch die Lösungen entwickelt.
Das heißt die technischen Lösungen liegen auf dem Tisch, die muss man entsprechend umsetzen.
Wenn Sie mit den wesentlichen Politikern reden … also es ist ja nicht so, dass die sich komplett dem verschließen.
Die haben ja dann auch, also ich war bei der CSU und habe Vorträge gehalten.
Bei den Grünen, wenn Sie mit den wesentlichen Politikern reden, dann sagen die, ja wir haben das Problem schon erkannt.
Unter vier Augen dann natürlich, nicht öffentlich.
Aber wir glauben nicht, dass die Lösungen, die wir brauchen, durchsetzbar sind.
Dann verlieren wir die nächste Wahl.
Das ist das Problem was wir haben, wir brauchen mehr Mut und wir bräuchten wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie was, was die Bevölkerung wachrüttelt, dass das auch …
Aber ich glaube auch fast, dass die Deutschen weiter sind, als die Politiker ihnen zutrauen.
Also das Unbehagen, dass da irgendwas mit dem Klima nicht stimmt, ist ja da.
Und wenn man das besser kommuniziert glaube ich schon, dass man mehr durchsetzen könnte, aber deswegen ist glaube ich das meiste, was einem fehlt, wirklich der Mut momentan, das einfach zu machen.
Ich meine die Unmittelbarkeit der Auswirkungen, das ist ja immer so ein Problem.
Luftverschmutzung, ja kann man irgendwie wenn sie sichtbar ist, dann geht das.
Da ist dann auch in China schnell viel passiert.
Weil es waren ja auch untragbare Zustände oder bzw. gibt es die auch teilweise immer noch in Indien.
Ähnliche Problematik, Mexiko hatte das schon vor längerer Zeit.
Da tut sich dann was.
Schadstoffe, die man nicht sieht, schon schwieriger.
Ähnlich dann eben mit dieser Temperatur, weil wie soll ich eine Temperatur wahrnehmen, wo wir als Mensch sowieso schon so schlechte Temperaturwahrnehmer sind.
Weil das ja immer alles relativ ist.
Also eine Temperatur ist ja immer nur, wenn ich zwei gleichzeitig anfasse, dann weiß ich was heißer ist, aber so absolut kann man es ja nicht wirklich spüren.
Und das ist natürlich dann auch ei dieser Wetterproblematik und ich kann das auch ganz unterstreichen, da bin ich ja mittlerweile auch schon alt genug, so dieses wie mal so ein Winter war.
Klar Erinnerungen trügen auch, aber es ist mittlerweile irgendwie dann doch schon so ein bisschen zu krass, als dass man wirklich sagen könnte, nönö das ist jetzt hier nur so die Spielart und so kenne ich das auch.
Sondern man vermisst einfach bestimmte Dinge bestimmt schon bzw. man trifft einfach auf Phänomene, die man soeben einfach in dieser Intensität nicht gekannt hat.
Die Orkane sind dabei eben nur so ein Beispiel.
Letztlich denke ich muss das Ganze aber aus so einem Bewusstsein der Gesellschaft heraus funktionieren.
Muss man sich natürlich jetzt vielleicht auch als Wissenschaft fragen, hat man einfach noch nicht genug auf den Tisch gelegt oder muss man da sozusagen auch mal über eine ganz andere Kommunikationsstrategie nachdenken?
Brauchen wir mal so einen Wissenschaftsstreik oder so?
Naja also irgendwas was sozusagen auch noch nie da gewesen ist.
Weil Wissenschaft funktioniert auch immer so ei bisschen vor sich hin, und wenn man die dann nicht ausreichend füttert, dann beklagt die sich so ein bisschen, dass sie hungrig ist, aber dass da mal so richtig einer auf den Tisch haut, das merkt man halt auch nicht so richtig.
Es gab jetzt so ein bisschen Widerstand so gegen dieses Trump-Movement und dann ist man auch mal so auf die Straße gegangen.
Das war schon mal so das erste Mal, dass man so das Gefühl hatte, okay, vielleicht bewegt sie sich doch.
Aber machen wir uns nichts vor, Wissenschaft wird auch so in der auch auch eher so als träge wahrgenommen, ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber hat eine gewisse Trägheit, die vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr Beschleunigung erfahren kann.
Ja würde ich eigentlich unterstreichen.
Also nicht nur bei Trump, wir hatten ja den Science-Marsch auch hier.
Den meinte ich auch genau.
Der kam auch hier in Deutschland.
Idee kam aus Amerika, aber da gab es Solidaritätsbewegungen, ich war auch da in Berlin am Demonstrieren.
War eigentlich spannend, man hat viele Kollegen aus dem Bereich gesehen, die zum ersten Mal auf einer Demo waren.
Also das ist irgendwie nicht so das Ding von Wissenschaftlern, in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen und zu demonstrieren.
Und ich glaube natürlich muss das also passieren.
Weil wenn man aus der Wissenschaft erkennt, dass da ein Problem ist, dann ist glaube ich auch die Verantwortung die Aufgabe, die Bevölkerung davor zu warnen und darauf aufmerksam zu machen.
Und nicht zu sagen, naja gut ich habe es jetzt gesehen und ich habe es jetzt mal in einem Paper aufgeschrieben, das hat jetzt keiner zur Kenntnis genommen, mehr kann ich nicht tun.
Also ich glaube da wird man auch der Verantwortung, die man da hat, nicht gerecht.
Die Vorgänge auf der Erde werden immer komplexer und schwieriger und sind auch von dem Laien gar nicht so zu sehen.
Also viele sehen auch nicht, was ich jetzt erläutert habe, was zum Beispiel in China passiert, dass die Deutsche Wirtschaft vielleicht auch Schwierigkeiten hat, wenn wir uns nicht mehr anpassen im Solarenergiebereich.
Und auch den Einfluss der Lobbygruppen ist für viele gar nicht mehr zu durchblicken.
Der eine redet so, der andere so.
Und ich glaube, gerade die Wissenschaft, die ja doch relativ unabhängig ist, also ich bin bezahlt hier vom Land Berlin und ich kann entweder Dienst nach Vorschrift machen oder ich kann mich jetzt irgendwie aus dem Fenster lehnen, ich krieg mein Geld so oder so.
Und deswegen hat man glaube ich auch eine gewisse Verantwortung.
Und da wäre es natürlich schön, wenn mehr Kollegen der auch gerecht werden und wenn wir einfach ein bisschen lauter werden und einfach sagen, okay stopp das sind Lobbyinteressen, da hängt Geld dahinter und das ist die Position der Wissenschaft und das müssen wir ganz klar kommunizieren, das ist die einzige Chance, wie man das entsprechend durchkämpft.
Weil es ist ein Problem, was ja, wie Sie schon gesagt haben, nicht so wirklich wahrnehmbar sind.
Also die richtigen Klimafolgen werden erst unsere Kinder dann erleben.
Und dann ist natürlich für viele, na gut und ob das dann kommt oder weiß ich nicht.
Also es ist halt einfach zu weit weg, dass es für viele klar ist.
Es ist für viele momentan noch nicht so wirklich spürbar.
Ich kann wunderbar noch nach Mallorca fliegen und gut, dann ist da halt mal zwei Grad heißer, ich schwitze und stöhne, dass der Sommer jetzt besonders heiß ist, aber es ist noch nicht so eine Konsequenz, die mein Leben irgendwie extrem beeinträchtigt.
Und dann ist halt einfach die Frage, ja alle haben ja doch Kinder oder Enkelkinder oder die meisten zumindest mal, also will man das auch dann dementsprechend zuordnen.
Also es gibt auch andere Bereiche, wo man dann auch versucht, ich würde ja auch meinem Kind keine dioxinverseuchte Milch irgendwie geben.
Auch wenn ich weiß, dass es in 20 Jahren erst Krebs davon kriegt.
Das ist ist ja auch so im Prinzip ein Problem, was eigentlich anerkannt wird.
Aber da ist einfach das wissen irgendwie, Dioxin ist böse, gibt man keinem Kind, das ist irgendwie bekannt.
Flug nach Mallorca zerstört das Klima für unsere nachfolgende Generation.
Der Zusammenhang ist bei vielen noch nicht ganz so offensichtlich und deswegen müssen wir einfach aufklären.
Vielleicht hilft dieser Podcast ja auch ein bisschen dabei.
Ja ich versuche ja gerade so ein bisschen was rauszubekommen.
Weil ich meine, wir werden uns ja hier eigentlich an jeden, aber eben auch so ein bisschen an die wissenschaftliche Gemeinschaft.
Und dieses ein bisschen lauter werden, was könnte das denn sein?
Also dann planen wir doch mal die Revolution.
Ist erst mal, ein Wissenschaftler schreibt ja erst mal gerne eine wissenschaftlich reviewtes Journal, ein Paper.
Und wenn das irgendwie dann in Fachkreisen dann zweimal zitiert wird, ist dann jeder stolz.
Das ist ganz gut, mache ich auch.
Aber das ist im Prinzip, da ist man in seiner Filterblase.
Absolut.
Paper von Wissenschaftlern für Wissenschaftler und man tauscht sich aus.
Und weiß, nachher wissen alle besser Bescheid, das ist auch wichtig.
Aber im Prinzip dieser Transport von dem aktuellen Wissen raus in die Bevölkerung, das ist glaube ich wichtig.
Ja aber es reicht ja nicht, wenn man sagt, ja was hast du denn gegen den Klimawandel getan?
Ja ich habe drei Absätze in meinem Paper dick unterstrichen.
Nein, aber ich versuche es ja auch.
Man kann irgendwie Podcast machen, man kann ein YouTube-Video dazu ins Netz stellen.
Man kann entsprechend auch Artikel versuchen in populärwissenschaftlichen Zeitungen.
Man kann sich auch einmischen.
Man kann ja auch im Wahlkampf auf die entsprechenden Abgeordneten zugehen und sie einfach dann mal auf öffentliche Sachen fragen.
Ja ich bin hier Wissenschaftler im Klimabereich oder im Energiebereich, wir sehen da ein Problem, wie geht ihr denn von der Politik damit um?
Also einfach mal das auch thematisieren, und zwar draußen.
Da wo das wirkliche Leben stattfindet und nicht in irgendwelchen wissenschaftlichen Fachkreisen.
Ich glaube das ist wichtig.
Und da fehlt einfach viel zu viel, dass da die Wissenschaftler einfach auch mal da hingehen und den Finger da reinhalten und zeigen, da ist das Problem.
Das würde schon helfen?
Helfen nicht, aber es wäre ein erster Schritt.
Na klar, aber ich kann mir gar nicht so recht vorstellen, dass das noch nicht stattfindet.
Also wenn ich jetzt so in dieser Rolle wäre als Wissenschaftler, das wäre ja sozusagen eigentlich schon so erstes Gebot.
Dass man jetzt einfach mal anfängt, eine Bande überhaupt eine Schnittstelle herzustellen zur Politik, die man vielleicht so vorher noch gar nicht hatte.
Also ich meine, sich darüber beklagen und das doof finden, ist das eine, aber dann eben auch mal diesen konkreten Schritt zu machen und den Hörer in die Hand zu nehmen, und wenn es nur der eigene Abgeordnete ist.
Im Idealfall ja auch noch jemand, der zuständig ist für einen bestimmten Bereich, den anzurufen.
Mal zu sagen: hier wir haben jetzt genug davon gehört.
Vielleicht ist das sogar noch der zweite Schritt.
Ich meine der erste ist, sich auch erst mal trauen, dann auch unbequeme wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse dann auch mal zu produzieren und zu kommunizieren.
Also ich bin ja auch schon relativ lange unterwegs, indem ich einfach mal einfach vor vielen Jahren ausgerechnet habe, was braucht man an Mengen an Solar- und Windenergie, um diese Energiewende zu schaffen.
Das ist ja jetzt nicht ein Ergebnis, was wir erst seit einem Jahr wissen.
Und ich bin auch aus der Community lange Zeit angefeindet worden, dass man sagte, das sind doch viel zu viel große Mengen, das glaubt dir doch keiner oder sonst irgendwie.
Also da gibt es auch so ein bisschen Angst vor dem Gesichtsverlust.
Also Wissenschaftler sind auch so ein bisschen Mainstreammenschen.
Also Angst, dass man zu laut geschrien hat so?
Also es ist ja dann immer so, es gibt eine wissenschaftliche Meinung und man hat ja vor 20 Jahren noch gesagt, mehr wie 4% erneuerbarer Strom geht nicht, dann bricht das Netz zusammen.
Und das waren ja auch … jetzt haben wir ja 35%, also das ist ja schon der Beweis, dass das totaler Quatsch war.
Aber das waren Themen, die an Hochschule irgendwie auch kommuniziert und geäußert wurden, auch von Professorenseite.
Und wenn es dann andere gibt, die sagen, nein das stimmt nicht, wir brauchen 100%, dann sagt der, du hast ja einen Vogel.
Und da fehlt auch der Mut, denke ich, in der Politik, auch mal wirklich andere Wahrheiten mehr zu verfolgen und zu kommunizieren und ein bisschen von dem Mainstream ab.
Glücklicherweise ist halt der Klimaschutz und die Energiewende jetzt auch zu einem Mainstreamthema geworden.
Aber es hat halt einfach auch 10 Jahre länger gedauert, weil auch viele Bereiche in der Wissenschaft einfach gesagt haben, das funktioniert nicht, das geht nicht, das ist irgendwie technisch nicht möglich.
Und wenn natürlich dann irgendwie die fünf führenden Wissenschaftler sagen, okay die Energiewende funktioniert in Deutschland technisch nicht, dann ist das natürlich auch erst mal tot.
Das heißt da hat man natürlich auch eine gewisse Verantwortung.
Zum Glück ändert sich das gerade ein bisschen, aber auch hier wurde natürlich viel falsch gemacht in der Vergangenheit.
Weil man einfach offensichtliche Sachen einfach verdrängt hat.
Das ist aber natürlich auch glaube ich sehr viel verlangt.
Aber das muss man auch von einem Wissenschaftler trotzdem verlangen können, dass er einfach auch mal die aktuelle Sichtweise hinterfragt und auch mal versucht, neue Wege zu denken und zu gehen.
Und das tun halt leider immer noch zu wenige.
Gibt es denn irgendeine Initiative aus dem wissenschaftlichen Bereich, die sich hier besonders engagiert, denen man sich gegebenenfalls anschließen könnte?
Naja es gibt immer so Strohfeuer.
Es gibt ja öfter dann schon mal Rundbriefe oder gerade vor Wahlen in dem Bereich.
Aber also es gibt den einen oder anderen, aber ich eiere jetzt so ein bisschen rum, es gibt jetzt nicht so die Organisation der kritischen Wissenschaftler.
So Wissenschaftler ohne Grenzen oder so was.
So wie es Ärzte ohne Grenzen gibt.
Naja eben.
Warum nicht?
Müsste man gründen ja.
Ja müsste man gründen.
Also ich denke das wäre vielleicht auch mal ein interessantes Signal, dass sich eben die Wissenschaft zusammentut und einfach sagt, hör mal geht schon lange nicht mehr so.
Nichts passiert.
Auf uns wird nicht gehört, jetzt organisieren wir jetzt hier mal den kollektiven Liebesentzug.
Die Wissenschaft ist da teilweise sehr vorsichtig.
Ich erinnere dann ein paar Kollegen aus Nordrhein-Westfalen haben dann so einen offenen Brief formuliert, als die Landesregierung gewechselt hat.
Also die neue Landesregierung in NRW wollte dann vor allem den Windenergieausbau deutlich reduzieren.
Auch Gebiete deutlich verbieten, was die Energiewende in Nordrhein-Westfalen deutlich zurückgeworfen hat.
Momentan ist es nicht ganz so schlimm gekommen bis jetzt, aber zumindest mal das was angekündigt war, war also ziemlich dramatisch.
Daraufhin haben sich da 20-30 Kollegen von der Hochschule zusammengetan und entsprechend ein wissenschaftliches Paper produziert.
Das wurde dann kassiert von dem Rektor der Hochschule.
Genau und der hat untersagt, den Namen der Hochschule im Zusammenhang mit diesem Papier zu verwenden.
Weil er Angst hat natürlich, das Land Nordrhein-Westfalen weist die Mittel der Hochschule zu.
Und wenn dann eine Hochschule sich zu unbequem gegenüber der Politik, dann hat man die Angst, dass die Gelder gekürzt werden.
Und das Denken ist leider auch da.
Ich halte das eigentlich für fatal.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass also eine Regierung sich traut, wenn da Leute eine wissenschaftliche Meinung unbequem aussprechen, auch wirklich dann den Finanzhahn zuzudrehen.
Das wären ja dann schon Verhältnisse wie in Russland oder in der Türkei.
Genau. Ich denke, das wäre in Deutschland auch skandalisierbar.
Ja genau.
Also da fehlt auch wieder der Mut, was wir vorhin gesagt haben.
Also da fehlt absolut der Mut von dem entsprechenden Rektor, der dann einfach sagt, okay lass die Leute mal laufen, ist doch auch Publicity für unsere Hochschule.
Und im Endeffekt kommt man mit der Politik ins Gespräch und das ist ja auch gut.
Das heißt, da gibt es auch viele, die entsprechend so was versuchen zu unterbinden, weil sie sich einfach dann auch nicht trauen.
Also mehr Mut brauchen wir auf alle Fälle, sonst wird das auch nichts.
Ja ich meine ist ja jetzt auch nicht meine Intension mit den Anmerkungen jetzt der Wissenschaft sozusagen den schwarzen Peter zuzuschieben.
Also Klimawandel gibt es ja nur, weil ihr nicht laut genug dagegen demonstriert habt.
Damit die tumben Massen aus ihrem Schlaf erwachen.
Aber sicherlich muss man jetzt hier einfach ein bisschen Beschleunigung mit ins Spiel reinbringen und da ist ja im Prinzip jede gesellschaftliche Gruppe gefragt.
So ein Mainstream, eine kollektive Wahrnehmung eines Problems nährt sich ja dann sozusagen auch aus der Dichte der Einschläge.
Also umso mehr solche Teilnachrichten aufkommen und umso mehr Gruppen diese eben auch mehr oder weniger heftig vertreten, umso mehr Bewusstsein schaffen wir damit sozusagen auch.
Bis das dann eben irgendsoein threshold, so einen Knackpunkt, so einen Mindestwert erreicht, ab dem dann eben vielleicht auch die Politiker dann antworten können, jetzt bekomme ich hier genug Druck von unten und bekommen genug …
Oder der Widerstand dagegen senkt sich.
Auf einmal ist die freie Sicht auf ein Feld nicht mehr ganz so wichtig, wie die Sicherung der Energie, um einfach die wirtschaftliche Leistung in der Region aufrechtzuerhalten und die Schadstoffe zu senken.
Klar, also das ist auf alle Fälle wichtig, dass man entsprechend sichtbar wird.
Und klar, wenn ich was zum ersten Mal höre, dann ist mal noch am zweifeln.
Und wenn man das dann halt 5-10 mal gehört hat, dann festigt sich das  und dann übernimmt man das auch irgendwie.
Und wer soll denn, wie gesagt nochmal, draußen die Leute aufklären?
Es ist einfach ein Thema, die Energieversorgung sicherzustellen ist sehr komplex.
Das ist dann auch bei Laien überhaupt nicht zu verstehen.
Also die Problematik, ob eine Leitung gebraucht wird oder nicht, wer soll das denn beurteilen aus Laiensicht?
Und das ist die eine Frage, und natürlich auch die Klimavorgänge, die sind sehr weit in die Zukunft weisend und da muss einfach die Forschung aufklären.
Also das denke ich mal ist schon ganz klar.
Und je häufiger und je besser das funktioniert, desto schneller werden wir den Wandel hinkriegen.
Ja Herr Quaschning, ich denke, jetzt sind wir an so einem Punkt angekommen, könnte man es noch auf einen letzten Appell auslaufen lassen.
Haben wir noch irgendeinen wichtigen Hinweis vermissen lassen?
Tja, Appell klar, Appell an die Wissenschaft wäre, sich dann mehr einzumischen.
Und Appell an die Politik, die Probleme ernst zu meinen, also vor allen Dingen diese Widersprüche zu beseitigen.
Ich kann nicht einerseits den Klimaschutz beschließen, Pariser Klimaschutzprotokoll unterschreiben und dann dahinter nichts entsprechend machen.
Und ich glaube das ist dann auch die Aufgabe der Wissenschaft, dann auf solche Widersprüche einfach hinzuweisen.
Wie wir das dann lösen, muss die Gesellschaft im Endeffekt klären.
Wir können ja auch aus der Wissenschaft nichts vorschreiben und sagen, das muss getan werden.
Aber zumindest mal können wir sagen, also wir widersprechen dem, dass wir einerseits uns als Deutschland zum Klimaschutz bekennen und nichts für tun.
Also eins von beidem ist eine Lüge.
Und das muss man dann auch einfach mal klar benennen und bekennen und ich glaube das ist unsere Aufgabe, das jetzt in nächster Zukunft zu machen.
Weil wir sehen, dass einfach auch diese Bereitschaft, da einfach mal Falschaussagen zu machen, international zunimmt.
Amerika ist ja das allerbeste Vorbild.
Aber wenn man in Deutschland hinguckt, ist das ja auch schon so ein bisschen verbreitet.
Dass man einerseits irgendwas verspricht und auf der anderen Seite weiß, man kann das schon gar nicht halten.
Also das ist ja auch eine Art von Unehrlichkeit.
Nicht gleich die absichtliche Lüge, aber Fehlversprechung, und da einfach den Finger weiter in die Wunde zu legen ist glaube ich wichtig.
Irgendjemand muss es ja tun und am besten können das natürlich die Leute tun, die aus der Wissenschaft kommen.
Trotzdem gibt es dieses Phänomen der Wissenschaftsskepsis, woraus immer die auch genährt ist.
Das ist irgendwie so ein …
Ich meine auch der Science-Marsch war ja im Prinzip ein wenig daraus genährt.
Es hat sich durch die Trump-Situation quasi nochmal verstärkt und nochmal so eine andere Stoßrichtung bekommen.
Aber grundsätzlich ist ja so dieses Glauben an unwissenschaftliche Prozesse oder diese Skepsis an wissenschaftlich gesicherten Wissen auch so ein Phänomen unserer diversifizierten Kommunikationskultur gerade.
Naja die Welt wird immer komplizierter, muss man ganz klar sagen.
Also durch das Vernetzte, die Welt wird immer zusammenhängender.
Also wir bauen jetzt, also ist ja ganz banal, wir machen jetzt nicht die Energiewende und irgendwann überrollen uns Elektroautos aus China.
Das sind ja Zusammenhänge, die hätte es vor 20 Jahren noch nicht gegeben.
Das heißt da hat man das in Deutschland entschieden, dass das in Deutschland passiert und da musste man nicht irgendwie beobachten, was am anderen Ende der Welt passiert, um zu gucken, dass Deutschland noch als Industriestaat in 20 Jahren noch mit vorne dabei ist.
Also deswegen das sind schon Veränderungen.
Und für den einzelnen auch wird das immer komplexer und immer schwerer zu verstehen.
Ich glaube die Leute sehnen sich auch nach einer geborgenen einfachen Welt.
Und da werden gerne Politiker gewählt, die einem versprechen, es ist alles ganz einfach.
Also das heißt die Populisten sind ja auch in der Politik im Auftrieb.
Also die Einfachheit.
Und Wissenschaftler neigen ja dazu, erst mal komplizierte Dinge zu betrachten.
Und viele können das leider auch nicht einfach erklären.
Und das ist natürlich, da ist man sozusagen das Symbol dafür, dass die Welt immer komplizierter wird und die sind mit dran schuld, weil die machen ja diesen ganzen komplizierten Kram.
Muss man sich aber stellen.
Vielleicht müssen die Wissenschaftler auch einfach mal lernen, komplizierte Sachen einfacher zu erklären und die Leute mitzunehmen.
Das ist vielleicht auch ganz wichtig, dass man also nicht irgendwo ein bisschen abgehoben ist und dann auch sagt, naja das ist eh zu kompliziert, das verstehst du nicht.
Da neigen ja auch einige dazu.
So dass man sich da auch wirklich die Mühe macht, ganz komplizierte Sachen so einfach runterzubrechen, dass man auch wirklich dann den Schüler aus der 4. Klasse mitnimmt, dass der das auch versteht.
Und das ist meines Erachtens gute Wissenschaft.
Und da muss auch die Wissenschaft von weg.
Immer wenn ich versuche dann aus dem Niveau, also komplizierte so runterzubrechen, dann sehe ich auch immer die Kollegen, die sagen, jetzt dreht Herr Quaschning wieder ab, das wird ja komplett unwissenschaftlich, was er macht.
Ich sage, nein das ist es gerade nicht.
Also das ist unsere Aufgabe, die komplizierten Sachverhalte auch für jedermann zugänglich zu machen und da scheitern einige dran.
Und da müssen einige glaube ich noch viel lernen.
Ich hoffe, wir sind heute nicht dran gescheitert.
Ich sage vielen Dank für die Ausführungen.
Danke auch für die Einladung.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist.
Bald geht es wieder weiter.
Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.